Qui se cache.
Bonsoir a tous, je vais vous appeler.
Bonsoir à tous et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce nouveau rendez vous
des Mardis de l'espace des sciences
dans cette dans ce bel auditorium
Hubert Curien des Champs libres.
Le rayon extraordinaire,
c'est le titre d'une exposition
qui vient d'être créée et mise en place
dans la salle Anita-Conti
des Champs Libres.
Et je vous engage vivement,
vraiment vivement à aller la voir.
Elle est née
de la collaboration de deux artistes,
d'un scientifique et aussi d'un musicien.
Et je les.
Je vais les appeler pour vous
les présenter
avant de discuter avec notre scientifique
Julien FAD, qui va nous donner
une belle conférence dans un instant.
Alors là, Flavien, Thierry,
Thierry, Flavien, Thierry et Fred Murry.
Voilà, les voilà.
Ce sont les
deux artistes
qui ont travaillé avec Julien Fades.
Et puis on va demander aussi
quand même à Thomas Poli, qui a composé
l'univers sonore de cette création,
de venir nous rejoindre.
Je vois que vous n'avez pas de micro,
alors je vais quand même vous en donner
un. Voilà, voilà, l'un de vous
le prend si vous.
Si vous voulez bien.
Voilà, c'est donc le fruit
d'un travail réalisé avec un scientifique.
Je crois que la rencontre s'est faite,
si je ne m'abuse, en 2015,
qui était l'année
internationale de la lumière.
C'est ça ?
Vous vous êtes rencontrés les uns
et les autres ?
Bon, il va parler beaucoup tout à l'heure.
Vous pouvez parler,
vous êtes rencontrés les uns et les autres
à cette occasion.
Et assez vite est né cette idée
de travailler, de travailler ensemble.
Je vais quand même vous présenter.
Flavien THIERRY.
Vous êtes diplômé de l'École supérieure
des arts
décoratifs de Strasbourg et Fred Murie.
Vous avez suivi un parcours scientifique.
Vous avez fait de la physique, je crois.
Et puis finalement,
ou je dit artiste mieux, oui,
c'est un peu ça.
Voilà.
Et puis vous êtes devenu artiste, mais
vous, l'un et l'autre, j'ai l'impression.
Vous êtes de grands curieux des sciences
l'art optique et cinétique,
les expérimentations numériques
et je crois déjà
la polarisation pour Flavien.
Vous voyez, alors c'est ce qui a amené
à la rencontre avec Julien en 2015.
Peut être s'apercevoir qu'en fait
on était sur des domaines de recherche
scientifique d'un côté et de recherches
plus plastiques de l'autre.
Sur des recherches qui avaient
des points communs et notamment
sur la question de l'utilisation
de la polarisation de la lumière.
Et il nous aura fallu quelques années
avant de trouver le contexte
qui nous a permis de travailler ensemble
et donc de présenter cette exposition
qui est tout juste inaugurée
et dont je pense,
Julien vous parlera aussi
en pas dans sa conférence
qui va rester en place jusqu'au jusqu'au
mois de mars.
Alors donc que vous, Thomas Pauli,
vous êtes venu rejoindre cette fine
équipe et vous imprégner de leur travail
avant de créer cet univers sonore.
Vous êtes musicien,
vous travaillez beaucoup en électronique.
Comment est ce qu'on dit
musique électronique ?
Personnellement, après plutôt musique
rock et chanson.
Par ailleurs, en accompagnant
d'autres artistes comme Dominique
A par exemple, a
une grande admiration, entre autres.
Oui et
les rencontre avec Flavien et Fred,
avec Flavien d'abord, s'est faite
il y a plusieurs années.
En 2016 je crois, et on a déjà collaboré
avec un premier album solo
que j'avais sorti de musique électronique,
où il avait réalisé la pochette
et ça semblait assez naturel de continuer.
Et le souhait des artistes
était d'avoir un
une exposition assez immersive.
Je crois que l'obscurité, en fait partie
et du coup,
que le son en fait partie aussi.
Et là, je suis intervenu pour composer et
et livrer
une pièce en album, un album.
L'album est sorti, l'album est sorti,
On a reçu les vinyles aujourd'hui même.
Donc c'est tout à fait récent.
Alors voilà, bravo, on va donner le
juste Encore un tout petit peu le micro
à Fred, peut être
que vous avez travaillé tous ensemble
avec.
Avec Julien, vous vous êtes immergés
même dans dans un labo,
Vous êtes des sortes de chercheurs,
vous aussi ?
Oui, oui, c'est sûr qu'on cherche
quelque chose différemment que Julien.
Mais c'est vrai
qu'on a eu vraiment plaisir à collaborer
avec Julien au sein de son laboratoire.
Ils nous ont accueillis à la
du Photon à l'université
et c'est vrai que ça nous a permis
d'explorer plein de pistes de recherches
pendant une année complète
au sein de son laboratoire.
Et depuis, on a pu réaliser une vingtaine
d'œuvres qui composent l'exposition.
Et juste pour dire un mot de l'exposition,
mais aller la voir Alors,
pour les internautes qui sont avec nous
ce soir et qui habitent parfois assez
Lou de Rennes, parce qu'il y a des gens
qui nous suivent de très très loin,
on mettra un petit lien sur
sur la retransmission
de notre de notre conférence de ce soir
pour vous permettre
de voir sur Vimeo
une sorte de visite virtuelle.
Un peu de de l'exposition,
ça c'est important.
Ce que j'aime bien, c'est en fait.
Vous avez essayé tous les deux
de donner à voir
et ça, il va nous expliquer ça
tout à l'heure.
Julien Donner à voir des choses
qui ne sont pas absolument visibles
pour nous autres, pour nous yeux humains,
pour notre vision humaine, si j'ose dire.
Ben oui, c'est une des caractéristiques
de la polarisation, c'est
qu'elle n'est pas perceptible.
Et nous, c'était pour certains animaux,
oui, mais pour l'œil humain en tout cas,
il ne l'est pas.
Et c'est vrai que ça a été pour nous
une préoccupation
de donner à voir cet invisible
et aussi de donner comme de l'utiliser
comme com, comme une manière
d'emmener le spectateur
vers un imaginaire qui est,
qui est à la portée qui nous entoure.
En fait, je ne sais pas
si la réalité vous la découvrirez.
Merci. Alors on laisse la place
aux scientifiques ce soir.
Voilà pour les mardis de l'espace
des sciences.
On va poser le micro là bas,
on vous allez aller dans la salle
si jamais vous aviez
des questions à leur poser.
Et bien sûr, vous n'hésiterai pas.
Moi, je vais demander à Julien d'aller
s'asseoir sur sur sur son fauteuil.
Merci à vous trois.
Merci à Yves-Marie Guivarch aussi.
Qui est responsable de cette salle
d'exposition
des Champs libres,
la salle Anita-Conti pour cette.
Pour vraiment cette belle
belle réalisation.
Vraiment là.
L'exposition est magnifique, originale.
Alors Julien Julien, vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'Institut
Fresnel de la Central
Méditerranée à Marseille.
On dit Central Méditerranée maintenant,
c'est récent, Non, C'était Central
Marseille avant ?
Oui, c'est tout récent.
l'École est en train,
donc c'est une école d'ingénieurs
du groupe de l'école centrale
qui s'appelait École centrale Marseille
jusqu'à il y a très, très peu de temps
début septembre, puisque là, l'école est
en train de s'étendre sur un campus à Nice
et donc
pour avoir
prend une dimension méditerranéenne.
Alors vous y êtes depuis septembre 2021,
mais pour parler de votre itinéraire,
on va dire.
Agrégation de physique en 2004.
Vous travaillez ensuite
une thèse en imagerie.
Pour l'instant, je prends mes notes
Polaris métrique et imagerie
quantique entre 2006 et 2009, à l'Institut
Fresnel de Marseille.
Déjà. Déjà,
ça se trouve du côté de Saint-Jérôme,
c'est ça
et ça dans les quartiers,
dans les quartiers Nord.
Vous faites votre post de doctorat
à l'Office national d'études
et de recherches aérospatiales,
l'Onera, à Palaiseau.
Vous y travailler sur
le traitement de l'information pour
la spectroscopie optique atmosphérique.
Je l'ai bien dit
vous êtes dentiste.
Recruté à l'université de Rennes en 2010
par le CNRS,
une université, une chaire CNRS,
une chaire CNRS pendant cinq ans
et puis ensuite
vous avez contribué à la création d'une
activité de recherche
en imagerie avancée au sein de l'hyper,
l'Institut de physique de Rennes,
qui deviendra l'Institut Photon en 2017.
C'est ça Alors Le département optique
de l'hyper institut de physique
a rejoint le laboratoire Photon
pour créer en 2017 l'Institut Photon
qui est maintenant un des ou le plus gros
laboratoire d'optique de Bretagne.
Deux équipes
à Rennes, une équipe à Lannion
et je me souviens qu'on avait déjà
collaboré ensemble en 2015, justement
L'année internationale de la lumière,
parce que vous étiez le référent
à l'époque,
avec une collègue de Maud Guézo,
qui est aussi pas mal active
dans la vulgarisation.
On était tous les deux coordonnait
les activités sur Rennes,
dans le secteur de Rennes,
de L'année internationale de la lumière.
Donc il y a eu pas mal de conférences ici,
au diapason.
Au moins, il y a eu un rappel des
illuminations monumentales
du Parlement de Bretagne pendant deux ans
sur justement
le thème d'une conférence d'optique.
Mais c'était Benoît QUÉRO
et son équipe de spectaculaires
Allumeurs d'images
qui avaient illuminé le Parlement
avec des différents
tableaux sur la lumière.
Et puis,
je crois que juste pour parler
de vos activités actuelles à Marseille,
je crois qu'ils vous ont accueillis
les bras ouverts,
avec plein de pleins
pleins de responsabilités.
Lesquelles ?
Là, je contribue à faire tourner
un master international de bio ingénierie.
Enfin une filière option bio ingénierie
et ainsi que la filière d'enseignement
en bio ingénierie de l'école centrale.
Il y a de l'optique, mais pas que.
Et puis sinon, donc je suis un chercheur
à l'Institut Fresnel
qui est un des plus gros labos d'optique,
du moins dans le Sud
et environ 200 200 personnes.
Et je suis dans une équipe d'imagerie
pour la biologie,
imagerie, imagerie et diagnostic
optique pour la bio,
avec notamment de la polarisation
et des milieux diffusant.
On en parle un tout petit peu
tout à l'heure.
Alors vous nous avez préparé ce soir
une belle conférence
qui s'intitule Le rayon extraordinaire
et ses applications modernes.
Vous avez préparé des manips aussi
à nous montrer.
Vous allez jongler entre entre tout ça.
Quelqu'un a dit Il va jouer à Garcimore ?
Oui, c'est un petit peu ça.
Sauf que Garcimore est resté tout.
Vous allez tout réussir ?
Bien sûr.
Je sais
que vous allez passer
une très très bonne soirée.
Vous allez voir qu'on apprend plein,
plein de choses.
Merci à Julien
Fabre d'être venu de Marseille à Rennes.
Merci à vous pour l'invitation retrouvée.
A tout de suite pour les questions.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
Donc c'était un très honoré
déjà d'être ici,
ce temps qui a reçu des grands, des grands
et des grands scientifiques.
Je me sens un peu petit
mais aussi un petit peu.
C'était un grand défi
parce que je ne voulais pas faire
un cours de physique
tel que je ferai à mes étudiants.
Je ne voulais pas vous faire
une conférence scientifique
telle que je vais à des collègues
qui ne voulaient pas vous faire
un catalogue de l'expo
et à côté,
vous irez voir si vous le souhaitez.
Je voulais
vous faire des manips, des démos
parce que c'est visuel.
La polarisation,
même si c'est,
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure,
un phénomène qui se voit pas
donc, et toujours aussi
un défi de vous faire comprendre
et de vous faire voir un phénomène
qu'on ne voit pas à l'œil.
On va essayer donc l'idée de cette conf.
C'est ça vous parler de ce phénomène
qui est assez fascinant,
qui a fasciné beaucoup de scientifiques,
beaucoup d'artistes
Et vous allez voir qui,
qui irradie dans plein, plein,
plein de domaines très importants
des sciences et même historiquement.
Donc on va commencer par se poser
la question
qu'est ce que c'est
que cette polarisation ?
On va essayer d'en donner une définition,
donc ça va être le parti
un peu court de physique.
Et puis après
on verra des applications déjà.
La polarisation, ça, ça parle de lumière.
Et puis dès qu'on dit lumière, en fait,
la lumière, c'est quoi ?
C'est un tout petit bout
qu'on voit avec nos yeux de ce qu'on
appelle le spectre visible.
C'est un tout petit bout
des ondes électromagnétiques qui couvre
des ondes radio
jusqu'aux ondes rayons gamma, rayons X.
Et donc, dans ce domaine,
de ce qu'on appelle le spectre
électromagnétique, nous,
on voit un tout petit bout
qui est le visible,
par extension en optique.
Les opticiens on manipule aussi
l'infrarouge, l'UV et voilà
donc en gros de l'infrarouge allumé
en passant par le visible.
Tout ça, ça va être de l'optique.
Alors
tout de
suite on va passer sur une première manip.
Donc quand on parle d'optique,
alors on a des sources de lumière.
Donc normalement, vous allez voir,
on a le petit plan de travail
que j'ai amené de plein de bazar.
Alors qu'est ce qu'on voit avec nos yeux
alors ?
On voit,
on voit la direction des rayons lumineux
qui vous permet
de former des images sur votre rétine.
Voyez la forme de ma main,
on voit l'intensité de la lumière.
Est ce que ça brille ?
Est ce que ça ne brille pas ?
On voit un peu de couleurs, ça,
on est capable de le faire.
Et puis, il y a d'autres choses
dans la lumière qu'on ne voit pas.
Alors comment
on peut mettre en évidence ces choses ?
Si je prends une source de
lumière telle que celle ci,
je prends un objet un petit peu absorbant.
Vous voyez qu'on a moins de lumière, J'en
ai un deuxième,
on a un peu moins de lumière, encore.
Puis si je multiplie les couches,
je absorbe de plus en plus.
Et si je tourne ce truc là,
il se passe rien de spécial.
Je prends une autre source de lumière
qui est celle
ci l'écran de cette télé modifiée.
On en parlera plus tard.
Comment les modifier ?
Mais voilà, j'ai le même phénomène
qui se passe.
Rien de très excitant. OK.
Alors après, je peux prendre
d'autres objets comme cet objet là.
Je vous dirai ce que c'est.
Juste après,
je le mets devant cette source de lumière.
Bon, ça absorbe, on a moins de lumière,
très bien.
OK, vous êtes venu pour rien. Bon
alors.
Sauf que quand je prends certaines
lumières et certains objets,
il se passe des trucs.
Regardez là, je me retrouve avec.
Quand même
un objet qui ici n'est pas absorbant,
mais ça ne dépend pas de son sens.
Alors que là,
vous voyez que je vais être capable
de laisser passer la lumière,
voire de l'éteindre complètement.
Alors ça veut dire que la lumière, c'est
un peu plus compliqué
que des simples rayons
ou des petits grains
qui se propagent vers nous.
Et une fois que j'ai en plus,
une fois que j'ai fait ça,
regardez une fois que j'ai laissé passer
la lumière à travers ce truc là,
même, cette lumière là qui était normale.
Et bien là, une fois que je suis passé
dans cet objet là,
ça y est, je suis à nouveau capable
d'éteindre, d'allumer.
Il se passe des trucs.
Alors, qu'est ce qui se passe,
Ce qui se passe que quand on essaye
de dessiner la lumière, c'est pas simple.
Quand on est prof, premier truc,
on fait entrer la lumière en ligne droite.
Très bien.
Alors un peu plus tard, les physiciens,
ils ont dit on va faire une ligne droite,
mais avec un petit oui, oui,
une petite queue comme ça.
Alors ça, pour les physiciens, c'est un
photon, ça veut dire un grain de lumière.
Alors pourquoi
on a fait une petite ondulation ?
Parce qu'entre temps,
l'histoire des sciences,
les physiciens se sont dit
il y a eu tout l'établissement
du modèle ondulatoire de la lumière.
La lumière, c'est
une onde électromagnétique, c'est à dire ?
C'est ce truc là, c'est à dire un objet
physique qui est le couple de deux.
On appelle ça des champs de champ,
un champ électrique.
Qui est ce champ ? Heu. La
en bleu et puis
un champ magnétique B qui sont attachés
l'un à l'autre et qui vibre.
Vous voyez qui oscille dans le temps
et dans l'espace en se propageant,
ils sont attachés.
On ne peut pas les détacher comme ça.
Pour avoir un photon,
il faut ou une onde, une onde optique.
Il faut ces deux, ces deux champs là.
Alors ça, ça explique ce modèle là.
Ça explique toute la théorie ondulatoire
de la lumière, les fameuses expériences.
Vous avez sans doute entendu parler
des fentes de Young ou des interférences
qui s'expliquent très,
très bien avec ce modèle d'ondes.
Le petit photon en bas, c'est
une vision corpusculaire.
C'est à dire ?
On va envoyer des grains de lumière
dans ces fentes.
Et alors ?
Vous savez qu'il y a peu,
une contradiction entre les deux ?
En réalité, quand vous
lisez les physiciens quantiques,
vous écoutez la révolution quantique.
Début du 20ᵉ.
On nous dit que c'est un photon.
Enfin, la lumière, c'est à la fois
des ondes, à la fois des particules.
Donc je vous invite à réécouter
les conf de Julien Bobrov
qui était là il y a quinze jours
ou à revenir à la prochaine.
Je n'aurais pas le temps
d'aller dans les détails,
mais en gros, ça s'est inspiré
des travaux de l'équipe de Julien Bobrov.
Voilà une tentative de représentation
du nombre corpuscule en même temps.
Entre les deux.
En même temps, c'est compliqué,
on n'arrive pas à se figurer.
Mais voilà, la lumière, c'est
un peu plus compliqué que tout ça.
Alors nous tester ?
Je ne vais pas m'étendre là dessus,
mais nous,
on va rester sur cette vision ondulatoire.
Alors ce que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure, ma petite lumière,
cette petite lumière
qui est somme toute normale, c'est
ce qu'on appelle la lumière polarisée.
C'est à dire
que le champ, eux dont on parlait,
ce champ électrique,
il oscille dans toutes les directions,
à la fois un peu mélangé.
Et puis,
quand je l'ai passé à travers cet objet
qui était un filtre, on appelle ça
un filtre polarisant, un polariseur.
Eh bien, c'est un objet
qui a pour propriété
de forcer le champ électrique
à vibrer dans une seule direction.
Et là, je l'ai forcé à vibrer
dans mon dessin en direction verticale.
Donc, on commence à comprendre
qu'une fois que je l'ai forcé à vibrer
dans une direction verticale,
ce qui va se passer pour lui
va dépendre de l'orientation
de mon champ par rapport aux objets
qui va se passer
quand ces objets ont
des effets de polarisation.
Alors, le cas le plus général,
je ne vais pas vous faire le cours.
Ça, c'est ce que je ferai à mes étudiants
en quelque une dizaine de minutes. Mais
le cours est le suivant, c'est
qu'en réalité, c'est
plus plus compliqué que ce simple cas là.
On peut faire des trucs plus compliqués.
Ce n'est pas toujours
une seule direction de vibration.
Ça peut être une trajectoire
un peu plus compliquée qu'une ligne
dans l'espace et dans le temps.
Ça peut être, dans le cas général,
une spirale, une ellipse, Excusez moi,
une ellipse qui se déplace
un peu en mouvement.
Spires à l'air et pour la décrire.
En réalité,
on peut décomposer le champ électrique
en deux parties.
Deux composantes du champ orthogonales.
Et en réalité, c'est le jeu
entre ces deux composantes qui va faire
que vous voyez ma polarisation
qui est ici l'envers.
Vous voyez,
c'est une polarisation rectiligne.
On dit que
mon champ oscille selon une droite
et je peux la faire incliné en changeant
l'épaisseur relative à la puissance
relative de mes deux champs.
Et puis en défaisant V, je recule une onde
par rapport à l'autre dans le temps.
Eh bien je vais donner de l'électricité.
On dit à mon champ, c'est à dire
je vais pouvoir le rendre plus ou moins
circulaire.
Cette trajectoire
va devenir plus ou moins circulaire
et donc je veux la rendre
carrément circulaire.
Alors après, il y a une autre propriété
de la polarisation
qui est ce que je suis en train de
manipuler là, c'est enregistrer un arrêt.
Je vais faire une pause quand même
parce que ça va très vite.
Cette propriété là, c'est de jouer
sur le degré de polarisation,
c'est à dire
que ma lumière, elle, peut être ordonnée.
Elle a une trajectoire
qui s'entretient dans le temps.
Mais je peux mettre un peu
mètre du désordre.
Il y a des phénomènes physiques
qui mettent du désordre là dedans.
Donc vous voyez que j'ai plus tout à fait
une belle ellipse bien pure.
Mais j'ai un truc un peu bruité
qui est quand même une forme elliptique,
mais ça ne se répète pas tout à fait
toujours pareil d'une ellipse à l'autre.
Et le cas extrême
c'est je peux faire des états complètement
des polarisées et je n'ai plus du tout
d'orientations préférentielles.
C'est ce qui sort de cet objet là, mais
je n'ai pas d'orientation préférentielle.
C'est ce qui sort de la plupart
des éclairages qui sont autour de nous.
Voilà, ça,
c'était pour ma partie cours de physique.
Mais on retenait ça
pour décrire la polarisation.
Il y a en gros une direction de l'ellipse.
Vous voyez, je peux incliner dans un sens
ou dans l'autre.
C'est ce que je faisais
en inclinant cet objet.
Et puis je peux avoir plus ou moins
de désordre dans ma polarisation,
c'est à dire une trajectoire qui est
très déterministe, très régulière ou bien
avec du désordre au cours du temps,
on peut faire une petite expérience.
Premièrement, je vais essayer
de vous faire je mettre comme ça ici.
Vous voyez, Cet objet que j'ai mis là
me permet de créer normalement
une lumière polarisée circulairement,
c'est à dire que ça décrit un cercle.
Et donc maintenant,
si je mets un polariseur comme ceci,
vous voyez,
je ne suis plus capable d'éteindre
parce que dans toutes les directions,
En fait,
je suis en train d'intercepter
cette trajectoire circulaire.
Donc en gros,
quelle que soit la position de ce filtre,
j'ai la même chose,
la même intensité ou quasiment.
Vous voyez très différent
de ce qui se passe
là où j'arrive à éteindre et allumer
complètement et puis je peux faire
de la lumière polarisée
en utilisant un papier calque qui est là.
Donc mon écran,
en réalité, émet de la lumière polarisée.
On a vu.
Et puis quand je passe
un papier calque devant,
eh bien vous voyez que là j'ai plus.
J'ai perdu cet effet particulier.
Un objet n'a pas changé,
ça reste un polariseur.
Mais le fait de passer dans un milieu
diffusant, aléatoire va me perturber.
On va mettre du désordre et du coup j'ai
récupéré une lumière totalement polarisée.
D'accord.
C'est cette manip
là que l'on vient de faire.
C'est à dire ?
J'avais une lumière polarisée
qui sortait de mon écran.
Et puis je suis passé dans mon papier
calque et j'ai mis du désordre.
Et j'ai quelque chose des polarisée
à la sortie. OK.
Alors avant de continuer la conférence,
j'ai été prélevé
dans une base de données qui a été fait
par des chercheurs du Japon.
Ils ont pris des images.
Toute une base de données,
d'images couleur.
Là, vous reconnaissez
des objets familiers.
Et puis ils ont fait de l'imagerie
polar symétrique.
On verra plus tard ce que c'est
l'imagerie paramétrique, comme on le fait.
Mais je voulais déjà vous donner à voir.
Qu'est ce qu'on y voit ?
Alors, qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on prend ces objets ?
Qu'on
regarde sur l'image que je viens de vous
afficher, C'est le taux de polarisation.
Est ce que la lumière est très polarisée ?
Fait briller le pixel ?
Est ce qu'elle n'est pas polarisée ?
Et je ne fais pas briller de pixel.
Qu'est ce qu'on voit ?
Pas grand chose.
Ce n'est pas absolument fascinant.
Et là, en bas, le bandeau du bas, c'est
l'angle de polarisation,
c'est à dire l'angle de mon ellipse.
Qu'est ce qu'on voit ?
Ce n'est pas fou non plus.
On commence à avoir des choses un peu
sur la pomme et sur le Rubik's Cube, là.
Alors d'autres exemples ?
Alors là, on va voir des choses
parce que vous voyez, l'écran de
ce téléphone est polarisé.
Donc on va commencer à voir très nettement
un signal ici,
en degré de polarisation,
en taux de polarisation
de la lumière qui est émise est brillante,
elle est polarisée.
On voit que sur les reflets, ça,
c'est une espèce de nous, sorte de
de vase de bouilloire en métal.
On voit que sur les reflets,
il y a de la polarisation qui se crée
et on voit que sur des papiers
cellophane aussi, il se passe des choses.
Et puis sur les angles. Là,
c'est intéressant.
Comment savoir
très clairement des choses sur l'écran ?
Et puis très clairement aussi,
en fonction de la direction
dans laquelle se reflète la lumière,
je vais avoir une information sur l'angle.
OK, c'est pas mal,
ce n'est pas fou non plus.
Qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on va dehors ?
Alors dehors, c'était des journées
où il y avait un peu de ciel couvert
en degrés de polarisation pareil,
c'est bon, plus le contraste sur l'écran.
Un pas fou,
ce n'est pas, c'est pas inoubliable.
On voit un peu des choses dans le ciel,
dans le ciel, notamment dans les endroits
où il y a du ciel bleu.
Puis sur l'angle aussi, on voit des choses
qui commencent à se passer
au niveau du ciel.
Alors, tout ça pour vous dire quoi ?
Le polar ? C'est décevant.
On peut arrêter ?
Non, on va quand même.
On peut faire des choses mieux.
Mais ça
explique sans doute pourquoi nos yeux
les yeux des animaux terrestres.
La plupart, ne sont pas développés
pour voir ce contraste.
Parce que dans la vie qui nous entoure,
il n'y a pas énormément d'informations
à gagner.
On va voir comment on peut en gagner,
mais directement, c'est pas, c'est pas ça.
Alors une grande application
qui est sans doute connue,
que vous connaissez sans doute, c'est
la polarisation des reflets.
Vous voyez ici un paysage de lacs
de montagnes avec des reflets très net.
Ici, à gauche et à droite,
c'est la même photo, mais prise à travers
un filtre polarisant tel que celui ci
et que s'il est bien orienté,
on coupe tous les reflets. Pourquoi ?
Parce que la lumière,
en se réfléchissant sur des surfaces,
va acquérir de la polarisation.
Le fait de se réfléchir
donne de la polarisation à la lumière
polarisée non linéaire horizontale.
Et si je mets devant mes verres
de lunettes des polariseurs verticaux,
ce qui a été fait sur l'image de droite,
je vais être capable de couper
ces reflets.
Grosse application pour les.
Pour les pêcheurs en nautisme,
ça permet de voir les récifs,
de voir les poissons, et cetera.
Un détournement de cet effet
était connu par Flavien depuis longtemps.
Flavien Terry,
qui utilise aussi cet effet là,
notamment aussi dans l'expo
pour révéler des choses.
Au niveau du reflet, il se passe un effet
de polarisation qui révèle des choses
et donc la grosse application,
comme je le disais, c'est ces lunettes.
Alors
cette personne est très importante
dans mon histoire parce que c'est lui.
Il s'appelle le Land em Land qui invente.
Comment fabriquer
ces polariseurs peu chers qu'on
appellera Polaroïd et des films Polaroïd ?
Le nom est resté.
Ce sont des polymères,
ce sont des films de polymère étiré
et en les étirant,
ça les rend très absorbants
dans une direction
et ça donne un effet polarisant.
Donc ça fait un sélectionneur
de direction, de vibrations de la lumière.
Et donc cette personne invente
au début du 20ᵉ
ces films de façon industrielle
et pas chers.
Voilà les pubs à l'époque.
Et puis voilà tout de suite.
L'idée vient d'une utilisation
commerciale
pour faire par exemple en croisant
de deux polariseurs
qu'on pourrait régler devant ces lunettes.
Mais on a un atténuation variable,
on a des lunettes de soleil variables.
Voilà.
Alors cette personne est surtout connue
pour cette marque
parce que le mot Polaroïd,
c'est l'émulsion instantanée
de photographie instantanée
qui se révèle à l'air libre.
C'est la même personne,
c'est monsieur Lambda qui l'a inventé
et qui avait fondé cette marque Polaroïd
et le mot
et le nom est resté jusqu'à
maintenant plus connu pour la partie,
la partie émulsion instantanée.
Alors dans quelle autre situation
vous avez de la polarisation dans
votre environnement ?
Dans le ciel bleu,
si vous regardez le ciel bleu
à travers un polariseurs tel que ceci.
C'est ce qui a été fait sur cette photo.
Vous voyez que vous êtes capable
d'atténuer, d'assombrir le ciel.
C'est beaucoup
utilisé en photographie aussi pour donner
des beaux paysages de ciels profonds.
Alors si je voulais me lancer
en explications, faudrait environ
deux bonnes heures et quelques dizaines
d'heures de rappel d'électronique.
On ne va pas le faire.
J'ai juste essayé de vous dire qu'est
ce qui se passe ?
C'est quand la lumière du soleil
interagit avec les particules
et les molécules de l'air ?
Notre atmosphère ?
Eh bien, elles vont venir interagir.
La lumière va venir
se coupler avec les électrons notamment,
qui sont autour de toutes ces molécules
ou ces atomes.
Ces particules, en se couplant,
elles vont les mettre en mouvement.
Et quand on met en mouvement des charges
comme des électrons,
ça rayonne, C'est à dire ça.
Les électrons vont eux mêmes.
Cette mise en mouvement
va rayonner, une lumière aussi.
Et ce rayonnement,
c'est ce que vous voyez ici
sur cette petite animation que je relance
cinq ou sept.
Ce rayonnement est assez anisotrope.
Ça veut dire qu'il
y a des endroits vers le bas, notamment
une forme de dôme vers le bas.
Ça résonne pas
et ça reviennent beaucoup sur les côtés.
Et donc cet effet là fait que c'est
un gros raccourci.
Mais cet effet là fait
que par rapport à la position du soleil,
eh bien, le ciel bleu
dans lequel vous avez cet effet
de ce qu'on appelle la diffusion
relais diffusion sur des toutes
petites particules beaucoup plus petite
que la longueur d'onde, est bien
la polarisation du ciel.
Le ciel prend une polarisation linéaire
qui dépend.
Ça marche très bien si vous avez
si vous récupéré des lunettes polarisées,
vous essayez à 90 degrés du soleil.
C'est ça et est là.
Vous regardez par là et vous aurez
un très beau contraste de polarisation.
Voilà, ça c'est ce qui a pu être mesuré.
On a très clairement aussi
un angle azimutale
qui dépend de la position
par rapport au soleil.
Alors bon, ça ça nous sert pas non plus
à part en photo,
mais ça sert à ces demoiselles
les abeilles.
C'est prouvé qu'elles ont une vision
l'art symétrique et qu'elles se servir.
Elles se servent
de la polarisation du ciel pour
s'orienter, pour s'aider à s'orienter.
Donc voilà, autour de nous,
finalement, il y a quelques sources
de lumière polarisée.
Votre exemple ?
Sur la lumière d'un arc en ciel,
vous voyez que dès qu'il y a des nuages,
de la brume, ça marque plus la brume.
C'est comme mon papier calque,
c'est très diffusant, ça mélange tout.
Il n'y a plus de polarisation,
mais ce qui se passe dans la double
réfraction dans les gouttelettes
d'arc en ciel.
Vous voyez que c'est très nettement
polarisé,
tangentiel à l'arc en ciel.
Vous voyez ici, on a un très fort signal
quand on analyse l'image à travers
un polariseur placé dans l'axe du
de l'arc en ciel.
Alors que quand on est en train d'analyser
dans une direction perpendiculaire
à la direction
d'Arc en ciel, on a plus rien.
Donc ça, c'était la petite introduction
sur le phénomène de polarisation.
Et maintenant
on va faire un retour historique sur
Et puis ça permet d'illustrer
des objets de l'exposition
historique
sur cette découverte de ce phénomène
et ce qu'on appelle ce fameux
rayon extraordinaire
qui donne le nom à l'exposition.
Alors là, je suis venu de faire
un petit rappel à nouveau de physique.
Mais vous savez, quand on propage
de la lumière dans un milieu homogène,
elle va tout droit.
Mais quand elle rencontre des interfaces,
la lumière se courbe.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la réfraction.
Et tout expérimenté,
ça soit sur des posters bien
connus de groupes de musique,
soit soit sur une vitre.
Bref, ça, c'est très connu.
Alors comment ça s'explique ?
C'est une question de vitesse.
En fait, c'est une question de vitesse.
Ça va être presque la seule équation
de l'exposition de la conférence.
C'est que c'est la vitesse de
la lumière dans le vide,
donc dans l'air, c'est quasiment ça.
Et dès qu'on rentre dans un matériau
qui n'est pas du vide, qui n'est
pas de l'air, qui est un peu plus dense,
comme ce bloc de verre,
et bien la lumière est freinée
parce qu'elle rencontre à nouveau,
elle rencontre de la matière.
On rencontre des atomes, des molécules,
des constituants de la matière
qui sont chargés en rencontrant
ces particules chargées, interagit
avec ce qui a pour résultat de la freiner
et d'avoir une vitesse de propagation
qui est plus petite
que la vitesse de la lumière c.
Et le rapport de la vitesse de la lumière
sur cette vitesse.
C'est ce qu'on définit comme étant
l'indice de réfraction
qu'on appellera petit n
en optique, on appelle ça l'indice optique
ou l'indice de réfraction.
Alors une petite analogie
qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut.
Vous m'excuserez,
c'est juste pour
essayer de faire comprendre le photon,
c'est un homme pressé.
Alors voilà un homme pressé
qui veut traverser.
Là, il est tranquille, il n'est pas très,
il traverse un milieu peu dense.
Et puis il a envie
de rejoindre cet autre milieu peu dense.
Mais entre les deux.
Manque de pot,
il y a une foule et cette foule massée,
l'équivalent de mes atomes,
qui est très dense, très tassée.
Et donc ce photon pressé
quand il veut se propager,
il est bien obligé de faire des serments
au passage de la foule.
Donc il va perdre du temps.
Interagir
avec tous ces constituants de la matière,
ça le freine
ou global.
Il va moins vite que dans le vide.
Et en fait, on peut montrer
que la trajectoire suivie par le photon
ou par le président précédent,
c'est la trajectoire la plus rapide.
Il va couper au plus haut, plus court.
En tout cas,
il va minimiser son temps de parcours.
Bref, voilà.
Comment expliquer
en trois mots la réfraction.
Alors la double
réfraction, c'est quoi ce phénomène
là qui survient ?
Qui a été observé en 1668 au Danemark
par un médecin qui s'appelait
Bartholomeus,
qui découvre sur des cristaux d'une pierre
qu'on appelait le spa de l'Islande,
qui est en fait
un cristal de calcite,
carbonate de calcium,
qui découvre qu'à travers cet objet,
on a deux images.
Voilà une image du logo de l'école
centrale à travers une pierre
de ce genre là.
Et vous voyez que, au lieu
d'avoir une image
comme à travers un bout de verre
classique, j'en ai deux.
Et ça, à l'époque, aucune théorie
ne peut expliquer ce phénomène.
Alors j'ai essayé de vous.
Je vais essayer de vous montrer
au labo à Marseille,
on avait un très très bel exemplaire.
Je vais essayer de
vous montrer ce qui se passe,
alors ça va bien marcher ici
ou là.
Il faut que je trouve un endroit
où ça marche bien.
Voilà, vous voyez le petit logo de tête
qu'on devine.
Vous voyez que selon la position, j'ai
un dédoublement très clair de l'image.
Vous arrivez à la voir
Les deux images, là, voilà.
En réalité, il n'y a qu'une image.
Si je mets un polariseur
normal, il y a qu'une image
à travers cette se cristal.
Je crée deux images un peu contrastées,
contrastées dans le sens contraire.
Et vous voyez que selon l'orientation,
je peux en faire apparaître
une ou l'autre.
Ça, ça vient du fait qu'en réalité,
le dédoublement des deux images se fait
selon la polarisation.
Et d'ailleurs, l'image qui sort.
Voilà, là, on va voir les deux images.
Est ce que ça va marcher ?
L'image qui sort, vous voyez ?
Il y a une des deux images
qui est polarisée dans un sens
et l'autre
image et polarisée dans l'autre sens.
Donc il y a un effet
très clair entre polarisation
et cet effet de double réfraction.
On appelle ça de double
dédoublement de l'image.
Alors
pour vous expliquer tout ça,
ce n'est pas facile et déjà à l'époque,
les gens s'arracher les cheveux,
alors ils avaient beaucoup de cheveux.
C'était bien.
Donc Bartolini fait ce genre de dessin,
Vous voyez à gauche
là, C'est le premier à observer cet effet.
Assez vite.
Huit Guns, on verra que c'est bien.
C'est la première bonne intuition.
Et Wiggins se creuse la tête aussi.
Il fait le même genre de schéma.
Et puis Newton aussi, à l'époque,
fait pareil pas.
Il ne sait pas y répondre
et répondait à beaucoup de choses.
Newton mais là il sait pas.
Donc voilà.
Alors oui, c'est le premier
qui donne les bonnes intuitions.
J'ai pas le temps de rentrer
dans les détails,
mais vraiment, c'est 20 ans
après la découverte de ce phénomène
et c'est
le père de la théorie ondulatoire.
Et on peut se dire que cette découverte
de la double réfraction, ça relance
un peu
la recherche sur la théorie de la lumière.
Alors je vais essayer d'expliquer
en deux mots qu'est ce qui se passe
de ce qu'on comprend maintenant.
En fait,
que regardez ces cristaux là s'écrit
On appelle ça des cristaux anisotropes,
c'est des cristaux.
La matière est organisée,
elle cristallise
dans une certaine direction qui n'est pas
dans une certaine configuration,
qui n'est pas isotrope.
Ça veut dire qu'on met les photons,
la lumière quand elle va se propager
dans la direction
V. Ces espèces de petit plan,
espèce de triangle, tous alignés,
tout ce qui se
comme des couches triangulaires, là voilà,
c'est ce sont les atomes de carbonates
des carbonates
qui sont tous un peu stockés.
Comme ça, on parlait les uns aux autres.
Eh bien, c'est plus facile pour la lumière
de se coupler
dans l'axe des plans
que dans l'autre sens.
Et donc ça explique
que dans une direction,
il sert plus demain que dans l'autre.
C'est comme si y avait une direction.
J'ai plus de mains acérées,
donc je vais moins vite
que dans l'autre direction
ou je peux me propager plus vite.
Ce qui donne l'effet
de cette double indice de réfraction.
Ça veut dire que
dans ce genre de cristaux,
la lumière, elle, a deux vitesses.
Pour se propager, elle a le choix,
elle n'a pas vraiment le choix,
mais elle utilise les deux vitesses,
ce qui crée deux rayons.
On peut voir ça un peu comme
un mécanisme dans le système de ressort
où je n'ai pas le même force de résistance
dans les deux directions
et donc j'ai à la fin pas la même vitesse.
Alors
là, je me suis dit à l'époque, on mettait
sa tête quand on faisait un dessin.
Alors
comme c'est moi qui ai fait ce dessin là,
je me suis demandé si c'était
une bonne idée de mettre ma tête.
En fait, non, on va pas le faire.
En plus, ce serait pas très présomptueux.
Je l'enlève.
Voilà comment on dessine ça actuellement.
Alors actuellement, on dessine ça
en se disant ben voilà, j'ai un faisceau
non polarisé de lumière
normale
qui va arriver dans ce morceau de cristal.
Le calcite comme celui ci
et qui va se dédoubler ?
Qui va obéir en fait à deux vitesses ?
Et alors ? Je n'ai pas du tout
le temps de vous expliquer.
Il faut 20 h de cours pour le faire, mais
pas du tout le temps de vous expliquer
pourquoi.
Mais dans cette configuration là,
non seulement il va avoir deux vitesses,
mais il va y a deux directions
et donc il va y avoir un rayon,
un de ceux qu'on a vu tout à l'heure. Là,
il y a un rayon qui va aller tout droit,
qui, historiquement,
a été appelé le rayon ordinaire.
Parce que finalement, et somme toute,
il va tout droit, il se comporte normal.
Et puis l'autre qui se décale.
Vous voyez, il y a un petit décalage
et il sort un second rayon.
Et ce second rayon a été appelé à l'époque
et c'est resté
toujours comme ça,
le rayon extraordinaire.
Alors pour comprendre ça, c'est il faut
à peu près 150 ans mois pour que là c'est
donc Monsieur Fresnel.
Dans le labo,
je suis maintenant porte son nom
Augustin Fresnel, ingénieurs
et scientifiques français qui filent
un bon coup final,
un bon coup de peinture.
Fidèle à la théorie ondulatoire
et notamment, il obtient cette équation
qui va de la deuxième équation
de la soirée et la dernière.
Une équation
un peu plus compliquée que celle d'avant,
qui nous donne en fait
comment résoudre,
comment, Comment calculer dans un objet
tel que ce cristal ?
Comment calculer les deux vitesses,
les deux indices.
Ça dépend de la direction
dans laquelle on va.
Ça dépend la direction
dans laquelle est placé mon cristal.
Et en fait, si vous regardez, si on trace,
on s'amuse à tracer
la solution de cette équation.
Ça, c'est une équation un peu compliquée.
Mais la solution, c'est une solution en 3D
qui a cette forme qui donne.
Vous avez sans doute
vu les affiches qui donnent
le visuel de l'exposition
Le Rayon extraordinaire,
cette espèce d'œil là
qui est omniprésent dans l'expo.
Si vous l'avez déjà vue ou si vous
y allez, cette forme là la fasciné.
Les artistes.
Ce n'est pas une forme qui a
une existence physique entre guillemets.
C'est une solution mathématique
de cette équation de Frenet, d'accord
qui permet de calculer et de prédire
ce qui se passe dans ce genre de matériau.
Et donc c'est cet effet là
qu'on exploite sur une des œuvres
où on envoie un faisceau de lasers blancs.
Donc c'est de la lumière laser blanc.
En fait, c'est trois lasers
rouge, vert, bleu combinés comme il faut
et les polarisations comme il faut.
Et on a un dédoublement des rayons
et une sélection des couleurs, justement
parce qu'on a mis les polarisations
comme il faut pour que ce soit beau.
Voilà, voilà une première vue,
conception initiale
de la pièce que vous voyez
maintenant dans l'expo.
Alors ça a donné aussi cette espèce
d'œil à cette forme
qu'on appelle la surface des ondes
ou la surface des indices de Fresnel.
Elle a donné lieu à une sculpture
que vous voyez exposée
dans l'expo Le Rayon extraordinaire,
qui a été imprimé à l'imprimante 3D
au FabLab de l'université.
Et voilà comment ça s'est fait
en accéléré, ont bien accéléré. Mais
on montre comme ça une pièce d'environ
50 cm de haut en plusieurs fois. Mais
on a un
petit peu la naissance de cette œuvre.
Alors ça, ça paraît déjà compliqué, mais
c'est dans des matériaux assez simples.
La calcite, c'est encore assez simple.
Il y a des matériaux plus compliqués
qu'on appelle des matériaux birks,
dans lesquels cette forme,
ce n'est pas un espèce d'œil,
ce n'est pas une espèce
d'œil qui englobe un autre, c'est
une espèce de double coquille
qui s'entrecroisent.
Et vous voyez une coupe ici,
c'est très, très joli.
Ce sont des modèles en plâtre.
À l'époque, pour l'enseignement,
on n'avait pas des machins 3D
qu'on pouvait tourner,
donc on créait des objets.
Les pères
créaient des objets en plâtre
démontable
pour montrer comment c'était agencé.
Donc je vais pas m'étendre là dessus
parce que quand on n'a pas du tout
le temps, je préfèrerais vous parler
des applications.
Mais voilà,
c'était un bel objet d'enseignement.
Alors en exploitant ce
phénomène, qu'est ce qui se passe
dans ces milieux anisotropes ?
Il se passe que j'ai deux.
Je vous ai dit J'ai deux directions
potentiellement de direction, de vitesse.
Et comme j'ai deux vitesses,
vous avez compris que je vais pouvoir
retarder
un axe de polarisation
par rapport à l'autre.
Mais si vous vous rappelez
ce que j'ai dit au tout début,
qu'est ce qui va définir la trajectoire ?
Est ce qu'elle est linéaire ou circulaire
ou elliptique ?
C'est justement ce retard.
Alors en jouant convenablement
avec le matériau que je vais mettre,
je vais pouvoir retarder
et changer la polarisation en faisant ça.
En venant mettre cet objet entre deux
polariseurs, je vais créer des couleurs.
Interférences.
Quand on éclaire en lumière blanche,
on va créer de ce genre de couleurs.
Ce qui est inspiré beaucoup
des pièces de l'expo et qui est utilisé
en minéralogie.
Ça, c'est des tables,
des abaques utilisées en minéralogie
où en fonction de l'épaisseur
de la lame de minerai qu'on a à tailler
et des couleurs qui sont observées.
Vous avez des abats qui vous permettent
de reconnaître
la nature de la roche
qui était qui était imagée.
Et là, en l'occurrence, sur cette œuvre
qui est exposée,
ce sont des lames de mica, un roche
qui est
qui est exposée entre polariseur croisé.
Alors là, quelques petites manips,
alors ça, ça va être plus joli, j'espère.
Alors la première, je vais vous montrer.
Voilà,
je me suis embêté à faire un pliage.
Vous reconnaissez un origami
d'une grue japonaise, donc éclairé
par en dessous en lumière polarisée,
et je vais venir l'analyser avec.
Là. Voilà, je vais venir l'analyser.
Vous voyez à travers
un polariseur croisé,
donc j'éteins la plupart de l'écran,
j'éteins, j'éteins la transmission
et voilà, quand je place un objet
qu'on appelle biréfringence,
c'est à dire qu'il
y a les propriétés de anisotropie
comme ce cristal.
Ça, c'est du cellophane
vulgaire cellophane.
Mais qui a ces propriétés ?
Vous pouvez faire avec des morceaux
de scotch aussi, ça marche.
Vous voyez qu'on
a en fonction de l'épaisseur traversé.
On va créer des couleurs,
donc ça donne des effets
assez assez jolis.
Ce que je peux vous montrer ici,
ça, c'est un petit scorpion
qui est pris dans de la résine
et en fait, en séchant,
on se refroidissant.
La résine va créer des contraintes
et on voit ces contraintes.
On les révèle
parce qu'elles vont créer des anisotropies
dans la matière qui donne ces effets.
Autre exemple sur un morceau de rapporteur
en plexi en plastique.
Là aussi,
dès que vous avez des contraintes,
on venir être capable de voir.
Oui, ça donne des effets assez esthétiques
de couleurs qui apparaissent
parce que les contraintes
qu'il y a dans le matériau
donnent ces anisotropies
et donc ça en fait, ça retarde un peu
les rayons l'un par rapport à l'autre,
ça crée ces transmissions
qui dépendent des couleurs.
Donc c'est utilisé
pas mal ça dans l'industrie
pour voir justement des défauts
sur des pièces transparentes,
voir des contraintes
alors on pourrait être un
tout petit peu plus clair.
Je peux vous montrer ce qui se passe avec.
J'ai pris une lame de verre, c'est
du verre tout ce qu'il y a de plus bête
et vous voyez
que si je prends une lame de verre,
pas le verre, c'est pas, c'est
pas anisotrope.
C'est un fait standard qui se passe.
Rien de très amusant.
Alors j'ai pris la même lame de verre
sur laquelle
j'ai placé un morceau de scotch.
Alors là, j'ai piqué ça.
Ma fille s'est rendu compte.
C'était pratique qu'on a que deux mains.
Alors regardez là,
j'ai juste la même lame de verre
sur laquelle collé un bout de scotch.
Qu'est ce qu'on voit ?
On voit que j'ai rallumé entre guillemets.
J'ai rallumé
une transmission de la lumière.
Ça, c'est intéressant.
J'avais polarisé ma lumière avec mon écran
comme ça, en
diagonale.
J'ai mis ici un filtre
qui vient laisser passer la lumière
que comme ça
et donc comme ça et comme ça,
ça ne passe pas, je bloque la lumière.
Sauf qu'entre
les deux j'ai rajouté cet objet
biréfringence qui va changer ?
Qui va faire que la lumière
qui était polarisée linéaire
va commencer à tourner
et donc elle a le droit de passer
à travers le second polariseur
qui est posé dessus.
Donc j'ouvre une transparence,
ça c'est intéressant.
Alors si j'en mets deux
deuxième bout de scotch avec du verre,
c'est le même scotch et la même épaisseur.
Vous voyez la même couleur.
Alors ce qui commence à devenir
intéressant, c'est quand je juxtapose.
Et là, on commence à comprendre.
On va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi il y a des couleurs.
Vous le voyez très clairement bleu, hein ?
Je pense que ça, c'est visuel,
on voit. L'interface est bien là.
Là où j'ai deux couches, c'est bleu.
Alors pourquoi c'est bleu ?
Parce qu'en réalité, pour le bleu,
vous voyez que ça va me donner
une audition.
La lumière bleue va mieux passer
en passant deux fois
dans les deux couches de scotch.
Et je pense que si je suis dans le rouge,
on ne voit pas très bien.
Si on voit un peu, vous voyez le carré
dans le rectangle noir.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que pour ce deux épaisseurs
de scotch là, pour la ligne,
la longueur d'onde rouge qui a une plus
grande longueur d'onde, eh bien, je vais.
En fait, j'allume la comme ça.
Je l'ai fait tourner d'un demi tour,
elle reste comme ça
et donc elle ne passe pas
à travers le second polariseur.
Tout comme la lumière de mon écran
du dessous.
Donc pour le bleu, ça passe
et pour le rouge j'ai extinction.
Donc vous voyez
qu'en jouant sur le matériau,
je vais mettre le nombre de couches
et la couleur.
Je vais être capable de créer
ces dégradés de couleur.
C'est ça qui
sur des objets plus compliqués, c'est ça
qui vous fait tous ces dégradés là ?
D'accord, c'est un ensemble.
En extrapolant cet effet,
on a l'explication de ces couleurs.
Interférences qui apparaissent.
OK, alors
voilà un exemple de ce qu'on
appelle de la stop graphique.
C'est exactement ce que je vous ai montré,
mais sur des objets transparents.
Vous reconnaissez
quand
c'est pris avec des beaux polariseurs
bien contrasté, ça fait des très belles
photos, c'est beaucoup utilisé.
On peut l'utiliser aussi pour imager,
ça donne de très jolies choses.
Ça, c'est quelqu'un, Richard Butler,
qui fait des photos magnifiques.
Il s'amuse à faire cristalliser
des différentes substances.
Là, je crois, me souvenir,
c'est de l'acide, de la vitamine C,
la vitamine
C, qu'il fait sécher, enfin cristallisé.
Et puis ensuite, il l'image.
Ça rentre entre deux polariseurs croisés,
comme c'est
ce que j'ai fait ici
avec mon écran et mon polariseur.
Et vous voyez les couleurs
qui apparaissent ?
C'est des couleurs de polarisation aussi
et en fonction de comment on tourne
le polariseur, vous avez différents
contrastes qui sortent.
On peut même le faire avec de l'eau.
Alors si vous faites geler de la glace
à température
et pression ambiante en dessous de zéro.
Je me suis amusé à faire ça l'an dernier
dans mon congèle.
Donc s'il vous faut faire geler sur
un millimètre un ou deux millimètres max,
eh bien vous voyez que vous avez
des effets de polarisation
de biréfringence dans la glace,
L'eau glacée, l'eau gelée
à la pression ambiante,
ça donne des effets de polarisation.
Alors ce n'était pas très joli
ce que j'ai fait moi.
Mais il y a des gens
qui sont bien meilleurs
et ça, c'est aussi de l'eau gelée
avec un dégradé d'épaisseur.
C'est très très épais,
puis on augmente l'épaisseur et vous voyez
que la cristallisation se fait
par des secteurs et chaque secteur
a une orientation bien particulière,
une épaisseur particulière
et ça fait des images magnifiques.
Voilà notre exemple En biologie,
c'est beaucoup utilisé
en microscopie
pour donner des contrastes de microscopie.
C'est un petit clin d'œil à un animal
qui nous est cher qu'est la seiche.
Ce sont des bébés seiches qui
ont été prises à l'université de Chicago
dans un microscope
dans lesquels on a équipé,
on éclaire en lumière polarisée,
on analyse
et on voit ces couleurs différentielles
qui renseignent sur bien des anisotropies,
des choses qui se passent dans la bulle,
dans les milieux biologiques.
Et ça, c'est un exemple de ce
polar symétrique
qu'on peut faire avec du scotch.
Alors on peut faire des jolies choses,
on peut faire ça.
Je suis moins fan
que ce que font mes collègues.
Alors ça, ça m'amène à la question
des cristaux liquides.
Parce que les cristaux liquides
qui nous entourent,
on a tous les pixels qui nous entourent
que j'utilise depuis tout à l'heure.
Vous avez chacun dans la poche
ou à la maison.
Eh bien, c'est basé sur des effets
Polaris, Metric, tous les affichages
à cristaux liquides, tout ce qui est LCD
derrière, c'est de la polarisation.
Alors ça, ça vient de la découverte
des cristaux liquides il y a du 19ᵉ.
Et puis c'est M.
Lehmann qu'on voit qui, dans son labo,
s'amuse à observer.
C'est ma première matière
qu'on a appelé des cristaux liquides,
qui a un état très particulier
de la matière qui peut cristalliser,
mais qui peut aussi fondre
et devenir tout à fait liquide.
Et il y a une transition de phase
qui a excité les physiciens.
La physique
statistique, on en est toujours d'ailleurs
pendant des centaines d'années,
ils sont plus de 100 ans maintenant.
En tout cas, ça donne à regarder
observer en lumière polarisée.
Ça donne ces franges là, fascinantes,
qui sont mobiles
et qui qui se meuvent au fur et à mesure
qu'on élève la température.
Donc là, ils avaient déjà conçu
un microscope polarisé
avec un thermostat pour chauffer
très régulièrement cette matière,
pour atteindre
ou dépasser la transition de phase
ou redescendre en dessous
de la transition de phase
au delà de laquelle l'objet
devient complètement isotrope
comme une flaque d'eau.
Et puis, quand on refroidit, on atteint,
on atteint des endroits où il se passe.
Ce genre de choses
comme vous voyez ici, là, ça, c'est
des images qui ont été prises
à l'Institut de chimie de Rennes
par Fred, Flavien et un collègue.
Il y a de mollard là qui ont pu.
Ils ont un microscope de ce genre là,
plus moderne, qui permet d'imager.
Et vous le voyez dans l'expo
qui permet d'imager ce genre d'effet ?
Donc vous voyez
qu'en jouant avec les cristaux liquides,
on peut faire des choses.
Alors l'intérêt
des cristaux liquides, c'est que ce sont
des matériaux composés de molécules
assez grosses qui peuvent basculer,
qu'on peut piloter
spatialement avec un champ électrique
et un champ électrique.
C'est assez facile à créer.
Il suffit de mettre une tension.
Ça, on sait bien gérer.
C'est de l'électronique.
Il faut se payer
des électrodes transparentes,
on met des électrodes de part et d'autre,
on met deux polariseurs croisés.
Donc normalement, on a extinction.
Et c'est ce que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure.
Si je prends deux polariseurs croisés,
je ne laisse pas passer la lumière.
Mais entre les deux, je met
une petite goutte de cristal liquide.
Et puis, de part et d'autre,
je mets des électrodes
dans lesquelles je vais pour appliquer
une tension, un petit voltage
et en appliquant une tension,
regardez ce qui se passe, on peut basculer
ces molécules du cristal liquide
et en les basculant, on va
pouvoir en gros jouer
sur l'effet de polarisation qui se passe.
C'est comme si j'avais
des matériaux tels que ceux là.
Vous avez vu dont on peut contrôler
la transparence un petit peu.
On pourrait les contrôler
en appliquant une tension.
Alors ça, c'est tout de suite fascinant
parce qu'on peut faire plein de choses.
On peut faire des pixels
grâce à ça, on fait des pixels,
c'est à dire qu'on est capable
d'allumer une transparence
ou d'éteindre une transparence simplement.
Mais dans une tension.
Et donc c'est à la base
de tous les afficheurs à cristaux liquides
qui nous entourent.
Un petit exemple
une petite manip à vous montrer.
Il y a donc ce que vous voyez
là, c'est un gros pixel.
Je le coince.
Donc voilà un gros pixel
sur lequel je vais.
Je l'éclaire en lumière polarisée.
Ici je vais mettre mon film polarisant.
Alors vous voyez que là il est
sympa.
Voilà, vous voyez.
Donc mon pixel est allumé
et là je vais me débrouiller
pour appliquer une petite tension
sur les électrodes.
Si mon fils n'est pas débranché,
ça devrait marcher.
Attention de ne pas
claquer.
J'ai un pixel, j'ai appliqué une petite
tension et j'ai basculé les molécules.
Mon pixel devient éteint.
Je peux le rallumer.
Ça m'a fait tout seul.
Je refais un coup,
je mets juste une petite tension.
J'éteins mon pixel.
Voilà comment marche vos télé
dans tous vos pixels.
Pixel marche comme ça.
Et donc ça, c'est
une aventure industrielle monstrueuse.
J'ai essayé
d'estimer, c'est très difficile,
mais j'ai trouvé une estimation.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'elle vaut,
mais quelqu'un a dit
ça pourrait être entre 10 milliards,
au moins 10 000 000 000
de milliards de pixels qui ont été créés
à base de cristaux liquides dans le monde.
Je ne sais pas si c'est du tout réaliste.
Le gars a fait une espèce d'estimation.
Je m'avance pas plus que ça,
mais en tout cas,
tout le monde en a dans sa poche.
C'est une application,
peut être la principale application
de la polarisation autour de nous.
Alors je continue parce que j'ai déjà
plus beaucoup de temps.
Donc ça, ça
donne la naissance à ses effets
à base d'écrans qui sont beaucoup
utilisés, exploités dans l'exposition.
Et puis là, je voudrais passer un tout
petit peu de temps sur polarisation
et la biologie puisque ça a inspiré
plusieurs des œuvres dans l'expo.
Alors première chose,
vous reconnaissez Louis Pasteur, donc
très grand, grand scientifique,
chimiste biologiste, physicien
et pasteur en fait, a eu un lien
très étroit avec la polarisation.
Il n'est pas le seul, mais c'est un peu
lui qui finit par comprendre un effet
très important qui est ce qu'on appelle
la stéréochimie, c'est à dire
le fait que vous pouvez créer
deux molécules tout à fait identiques.
Si vous regardez ces deux molécules
là, c'est du limonène.
On appelle ça.
Elles sont strictement identiques,
à ceci près que elles, ce sont.
Elles ne sont pas conformées.
Tout à fait
pareil dans l'espace comme nom.
Mais demain, si vous regardez
vos deux mains, elles sont identiques.
Sauf que là, il y en a une,
une droite et une gauche,
et vous ne pouvez pas les superposer.
Vous ne pouvez pas superposer votre main
avec la main gauche,
vous ne pouvez, vous pouvez chercher,
ça ne marche pas.
Donc vous prenez votre main,
vous la mettez devant un miroir,
vous choper la main du miroir,
vous essayez de la superposer,
ça ne marche pas.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un objet
chiral, c'est la chiralité, C'est le fait
qu'on ne peut pas superposer
un objet et son image.
Ces deux molécules, c'est ce qu'on
appelle du limonène gauche et du limonène.
Trois Ne peuvent pas se superposer
l'image de l'autre dans un miroir.
Et ça, c'est assez fascinant.
C'est que vous allez,
vous les connaissez, ces molécules ?
Parce qu'il y en a une qui
a plutôt l'odeur du citron et l'autre
plutôt l'odeur de l'orange.
C'est utilisé en parfumerie
et c'est fascinant de se dire que c'est
la même molécule.
Exactement.
Le seul truc qui change, c'est
une conformation spatiale.
Notre nez est capable de faire
la différence, capable
de sentir lune qui sent plutôt le citron
et note plutôt l'eucalyptus.
Et c'est pas les seuls.
Pasteur découvre notamment en étudiant
de l'acide tartrique, qu'un acide du vin.
Il étudie cela et il se rend compte
que quand on essaye de produire de l'acide
tartrique industriellement, eh bien on a
un mélange des deux molécules.
Alors que quand on prend
de l'acide tartrique biologique
créé par la biologie pure et par la vigne,
on en a qu'un. Des sels mélangés.
Comme on le voit, ça, on le voit
parce que quand on a des molécules chirale
comme ceci, et bien elles ont un effet
d'entraînement de la polarisation.
Ça veut dire que si je les éclaire
avec une polarisation
comme ça, je éclaire une solution diluée
de ce genre d'objets.
La polarisation va tourner.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'activité optique.
Alors c'est pas Pasteur qui découvre ça,
mais c'est lui qui finit par l'identifier.
Qui a cet effet de symétrie ?
Parce que quand on les crée
industriellement,
on crée les deux formes en même temps,
alors que la biologie
n'en crée qu'une seule.
Donc voilà, c'est ça que je vous disais
vous voyez, si je crée de la lumière
non polarisée, je la polarise
et je la passe dans une cuve
qui contient ce genre de substance.
Eh bien, ma polarisation va basculer
une rotation du plan de polarisation.
Ça, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'activité
optique et qui est à la base de ces
mesures de fin,
de cette découverte de pasteur.
Et c'est très utile en chimie
parce que ça permet de doser
des solutions, de vérifier la pureté
d'une solution, et cetera
Ça, c'est
une petite manip que j'ai fait chez moi.
Alors vous avez une lumière
non polarisée ?
Un polariseur
devant. Je suis en train de balader
un autre polariseur
que je peux éteindre ou allumer.
Là vous avez un verre d'eau,
alors l'eau et il se passe.
Rien de spécial.
Maintenant le slide
d'après vous avez la même chose, mais sauf
qu'à gauche vous avez du fructose, donc
un sucre issu du fruit et du saccharose.
Un sucre industriel.
Vous allez
voir qu'il y en a un
qui va me permettre de tourner.
Tourne le plan de polar plutôt à gauche
et l'autre plutôt à droite.
Un sucre industriel forme droite,
un sucre naturel forme gauche.
Vous voyez, j'ai plus l'extinction
au même endroit.
Au milieu, vous avez l'eau comme témoin
que l'eau va couper la polarisation
comme un bon polariseur,
comme dans un cas comme dans l'air.
Mais mes deux solutions sucrées
la coupure l'angle
d'extinction va paraître au même endroit.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'activité optique.
Le fait que c'est dans ce verre de gauche
et le vert de droite
que j'ai fait tourner mes polarisations.
Dans le même sens.
Alors ça, ça
nous avait donné des idées d'installation
qui finalement ne sont pas dans l'expo.
Mais ça fait des choses très jolies,
comme ce genre
d'objets de spirale dans du sucre.
Là, on peut faire une spirale colorée,
mais malheureusement,
on n'a pas pu la mener à bien.
Et voilà un peu
une illustration de ce qu'on peut faire
alors d'autres propriétés
fascinantes qui regardent la biologie
et ces animaux là.
Là aussi, ça aurait pu faire un.
L'animation ne se lance pas.
Si ces animaux là,
ce sont des scarabées particuliers
qui ont une propriété assez unique, c'est
de créer de la polarisation circulaire.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
on peut voir des polarisations circulaires
droite
tourne à droite, gauche tourne à gauche.
Et bien ces animaux là.
J'ai un exemple ici
pour faire une petite manip.
J'en ai un empaillé en résine.
Je vais l'éclairer.
Attendez hop,
je vais l'éclairer avec de la lumière
non polarisée qu'une lumière classique
et regarder ce qui se passe ici.
Ce sont des lunettes que vous utilisez
au cinéma, Ce sont des lunettes qui sont
des polariseurs circulaires, donc
un œil gauche circulaire gauche droite.
Circuler librement l'air droit,
voilà ce premier polariseur.
Mon scarabée est bien bien brillant
à travers le second,
mais mon scarabée
complètement noir,
ça veut dire que la lumière qui est
réfléchie par la carapace de scarabée
a donné une polarisation gauche
et non pas droite.
Elle a vraiment, et c'est un
des rares objets biologiques qui crée de
la polarisation par réflexion
de polarisation droite ou gauche.
Tous ces phénomènes là,
pourquoi je vous en parle ?
C'est assez fascinant, parce que c'est
un problème qui n'est pas résolu,
qu'on appelle l'homo
qui irréalité du vivant, qui est d'essayer
d'expliquer pourquoi toute la biologie
donne des formes.
Parce que si vous prenez
tous les scarabées du monde
et je pense que tous les scarabées,
vous voyez,
c'est une photo qui a été prise
avec toute une collection de scarabées
qui présentent ces propriétés.
Vous voyez leur image
dans un miroir et noir.
Pourquoi ?
Parce Qu'on en fait,
On est en train d'imager ces scarabées
à travers un polariseur circulaire gauche,
donc on les voit briller.
Sauf que, à la réflexion,
dans un miroir, la polarisation tourne
et donc on éteint les
images de ces scarabées et voyez
qui sont tous polarisés dans le même axe.
Il y en a pas un seul qui brille à droite
et à gauche.
Et la question est
pourquoi tous les sucres
de l'ADN tournent à droite et pourquoi
toutes les protéines tournent à gauche ?
Ça, c'est un mystère de la biologie.
Alors il y a des pistes.
En tout cas, ça semble éclairer
l'hypothèse qui est que tout, tout
le vivant est parti d'une racine unique
qui part ensuite par duplication.
Tous les mécanismes de la biologie,
de duplication, de réplication font
qu'on a entretenu une direction
et jamais l'autre.
D'accord, c'est assez fascinant.
Un autre chose fascinant
qui nous a énormément excité,
c'est la seiche,
qui est un animal fantastique.
Parce que d'une part, ça fait partie
de ces animaux qui voient la polarisation.
Parce que dans leur rétine, en fait,
elle a des petits, des comment dire,
des capteurs qui sont
sur deux axes orthogonaux,
donc ça lui permet de voir
un contraste de polarisation.
C'est la même inspirée récemment,
c'est un papier très récent de gens
qui ont essayé
d'utiliser ça sous l'eau pour s'orienter
par rapport aux rayons du soleil.
Mais encore mieux.
La seiche, c'est pour le coup
le seul animal qu'on pense être capable
de créer avec des organes
qu'on appelle des rideaux forts.
Qui sont ces petits trucs
là ? Il faut bien zoomer.
Vous voyez, ça ressemble à ça
des petites plaquettes qui, sur certaines
parties, des bras tentacules de la seiche
qui sont capables de s'orienter.
Et à la réflexion sur ces rideaux forts,
la lumière, prendre la polarisation.
Donc, ce sont des animaux
qui savent créer de la polarisation.
Et voilà les premières images. Ça,
c'est un public.
On avait trouvé qui datent des années 90,
qui étaient les premières images
en lumière polarisée d'une seiche
en contrastes polarisation.
Vous voyez en rouge
apparaître ces signaux ?
Et alors là, il y a une hypothèse
qu'on aime croire.
C'est pas encore prouvé, prouvé,
mais on aime à croire que
c'est ce qu'on met un peu en scène
dans l'exposition.
C'est ce qui est mis en scène, c'est
On aime à croire que c'est un espèce
de message secret, de langage secret.
Entre entre seiche qui serait capable
de se causer à l'insu des autres animaux.
Donc, on est allé faire des captations.
Les images que vous voyez dans l'expo,
les œuvres sont tirées de captations
qu'on a fait au marina de Concarneau,
où on est allé avec une petite caméra
Polaris, Metric, filmer une seiche.
Et ça a donné ces œuvres là,
comme cette tapisserie.
Alors
je passe à une autre partie du discours.
Je voulais vous parler d'imagerie,
un peu des applications, de l'imagerie
polarisation.
Un exemple de ce qu'on a pu faire à Rennes
quand j'étais avec mes collègues
de l'institut Foton
et avec des collègues d'Inde.
On s'est posé la question
d'essayer de résoudre le problème suivant
qui est quand
on est en situation de brouillard,
on ne voit plus les balises
d'une piste quand on veut atterrir.
Alors, on s'est posé la question
est ce qu'une solution pas chère,
ça pourrait être d'équiper les balises
de la piste avec des petits polariseur ?
Ça, ça coûte rien.
Et d'équiper l'avion le pilote d'un
système d'imagerie Polaris métrique
qui est représenté ici.
Alors là, vous reconnaissez quoi ?
Vous reconnaissez une caméra
au bout et puis un cube,
un truc qui ressemble à ce cristal là,
qui va être capable de couper
la polarisation en deux
rayons ordinaires extraordinaires
et de polariser à la fois.
Et en faisant ça,
on est capable de faire deux images
qui sont à 15 à 30 avec deux
polarisations orthogonales,
comme si on avait mis devant
chacun de nos yeux
des polariseurs croisés
et en faisant la différence.
En combinant
ces deux images, on va pouvoir obtenir
une information de polarisation.
Et un petit exemple de ce cas.
Ça a pu donner.
Vous voyez ici, ça,
c'était la balise lumineuse.
On l'avait placée au sommet
de la tour de communication TDF,
à la sortie de Rennes, à l'ouest, à l'est
et voilà le genre de résultat
d'un petit film qui devait s'élancer.
Voilà ce qu'on a au cours du temps.
Vous voyez à gauche,
c'est ce qu'on verrait à l'œil nu.
Et l'image de droite, c'est
le résultat du traitement optimal de polar
symétrique qu'on peut faire à travers
un système instantané temps réel.
Il y a un calcul relativement simple
mais optimisé,
et vous voyez qu'on est capable
de restituer la position des balises
avec un très bon contraste,
beaucoup mieux que si on avait tout
cet environnement de brouillard.
Donc ça faisait partie des applications
qu'on pourrait imaginer avec
des gains assez significatifs
en visibilité,
un facteur dix
au mieux sur la visibilité de ces balises.
Alors on est allé un peu plus loin.
On a fait la même chose avec des imageur
couleur
et là, ça donne des choses assez rigolo.
Ici, vous avez des papillons,
deux moitiés de papillon,
un faux papillon imprimé replacé,
un vrai papillon morpho du Brésil bleu et
Et là, en fait, ce qui se passe, c'est
que quand on fait de l'imagerie
de polarisation sur des objets comme ça
des objets pigmentés, on a un effet.
Si on regarde le taux de polarisation
de la lumière qui revient bien,
on a un effet d'inversion des couleurs.
Donc ça, c'est l'image en haut.
Là, c'est l'image
couleur classique et en bas, c'est l'image
du taux de polarisation encodé en couleur.
Donc ça veut dire qu'ici,
sur le stylo de gauche,
eh bien la lumière bleue
revient très polarisée
alors que la lumière rouge et polarisée,
on ne la voit pas sur l'image du bas.
Et c'est l'inverse pour ce stylo là.
Vous voyez, la lumière est bleue,
j'ai majoritairement du bleu qui revient,
mais le bleu est polarisé,
donc je la vois pas sur l'image du bas
et je ne vois de la polarisation
que sur l'image.
Sur la couleur rouge, je parle et donc
on a un effet d'inversion des couleurs
assez significatif
qui s'appelle l'effet ou MOF
et qui vient donner de ces raisons là,
c'est que le rouge sur un matériau rouge
rentre dans le matériau n'est pas absorbé,
donc il a le temps de se dépolarisation,
d'être perturbé, d'être rendu aléatoire,
alors que les autres couleurs
vont se réfléchir uniquement à la surface,
sont très vite absorbées
et la réflexion à la surface.
On l'a dit tout à l'heure,
ça conserve la polarisation.
J'ai oublié de préciser
que dans cette expérience là,
on éclaire
avec de la lumière polarisée déjà.
Et si on le fait sur un vrai papillon ?
Et la partie de droite ici,
sur un vrai papillon bleu,
on a beaucoup moins cet effet.
On a presque pas ça,
ça vient du fait qu'ici,
on met en évidence
que ce n'est pas une couleur pigmentaire.
Ce n'est pas un effet d'absorption
sur ces papillons là.
La couleur bleue vient
d'un effet d'interférence,
c'est à dire que la lumière diffractée
interfère sur des structures nanométriques
à la surface des plumes
des ailes de papillons.
Et c'est vraiment un effet d'interférence.
Le bleu interfère et le rouge interfère.
Destructives,
ce qu'on appelle les couleurs.
Interférence.
Alors C'est beaucoup utilisé aussi
en imagerie
pour la défense
puisque ça permet de camoufler.
Vous voyez, si vous avez un œil,
alors ce sont des jouets.
C'est un avion métallisé.
Ici, c'est un faux avion.
On arrive bien à les mettre en évidence
sur une image de contraste,
de polarisation.
Ici, un autre exemple
on peut mettre en évidence
un objet métallique posé au milieu
d'un champ.
Ici, vous voyez,
derrière un filet de camouflage,
on n'y voit rien, mais en polarisation,
on arrive à restituer la forme du vélo.
Et puis nous, on s'est dans l'exposition.
On s'est intéressé à ça
pour se poser la question de
comment je donne à voir cette polarisation
puisque je acquiert
une information supplémentaire.
Ce n'est pas de la couleur,
ce n'est pas l'intensité.
C'est un truc en plus que je ne vois pas
comment je peux le donner à voir
comment je peux le donner à représenter.
Et la solution qui nous est venue,
c'était de se dire
on va tirer sur les pixels,
jouer sur la 3D.
On part d'une image à deux dimensions
et là où c'est
la lumière est restée très polarisée,
on tire vers le haut le pixel,
on crée un paysage,
on le monte vers le haut.
Donc, sur toutes les œuvres
que vous allez voir dans l'expo,
quand vous avez des sommets
là bas, ce sont des endroits
où la lumière est restée très polarisée
alors que dans les vallées,
c'est des endroits
où la lumière est totalement polarisée.
Alors on peut aller beaucoup plus loin.
J'ai commencé à aller un peu plus vite
pour parler des applications.
Ici, vous avez
un type d'imagerie classique.
En fait, pour faire de l'imagerie
colorimétrique, bien souvent,
on met un détecteur,
puis on met des filtres polarisants
de différentes configurations.
On fait plein d'images,
on les combine et on obtient des infos.
Alors quand on fait ça,
on peut faire plein de plis.
On peut reconstituer des formes
en trois dimensions
de topologie en 3D d'un objet.
Comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure.
Vous vous souvenez sur mes matières,
la direction de polarisation m'indique
l'angle, la géométrie de l'objet.
On le voit très bien
ici, sur la voiture en bas
ou sur ce container poubelle,
on voit que la direction de l'angle
me permet de reconstituer la 3D,
le volume.
Donc ça, ça fait partie des applications
possibles.
Grosse
application en imagerie biomédicale.
Alors là, c'est des collègues de Paris
de Palaiseau qui font ça à Polytechnique,
ce qu'on appelle l'imagerie de Müller.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails.
C'est l'imagerie la plus complexe.
On a besoin de seize images,
mais quand on a fait les seize images,
oui, ça, c'est une cartographie de seize
images d'un morceau de col de l'utérus
malade en l'occurrence.
Et de ces seize images, on est capable de
reconstituer, c'est tout un savoir faire.
On est capable de reconstituer
des cartographies
de ce qu'on appelle la retardant,
la dit atténuation et la dépolarisation,
peu importe ce que c'est.
Ce qui est intéressant de voir, c'est
qu'on est capable.
Vous voyez, par rapport
à un morceau de col 100
et un morceau malade,
on est capable de très nettement
les mettre en évidence
grâce à des contrastes de polarisation.
Et l'ambition, c'est
un jour d'aller faire ça
dans le corps humain, en endoscopie,
en passant par des fibres.
Ça, c'est encore un défi à mener.
D'autres exemples
maintenant en microscopie cellulaire,
beaucoup plus on rentre
plus dans détails dans la cellule,
on peut aller faire des choses extrêmement
belles à Fresnel, dans une équipe.
C'est pas mon, mais c'est
une équipe de microscopie avancée.
Ils sont capables maintenant
d'aller imager sur des molécules uniques
l'orientation des molécules
grâce à la polarisation dans des fibrilles
toute petite.
Là, on est vraiment à des dimensions
nanométrique, quasiment.
On est capable d'imager
des molécules uniques et leurs directions,
d'autres très images,
comme ça s'est fait aux États-Unis.
Là aussi, on est capable de voir si c'est
un cerveau de mouche
très agrandi. C'est de la microscopie.
On est capable
d'aller vraiment voir les fibres nerveuses
et mesurer ces orientations.
Le fait que la polarisation, vous vous
rappelez, c'est vraiment très ordonné.
Ça dépend de l'angle
de la direction de vibration.
Ça va me donner des infos
sur l'organisation de la matière.
C'est ça qu'il faut retenir.
Bon, ça, j'ai pas le temps.
C'est ce qu'on faisait à Rennes, mais
on en parlera dans les questions
si vous le souhaitez.
Je vais prendre quelques minutes
pour vous parler des applications
les plus modernes.
Est ce qu'il y a plein de trucs
chouettes aussi ?
En deux mots,
une petite révolution depuis quelques
années sur l'imagerie de polarisation.
C'est des nouveaux capteurs
où maintenant on est capable de créer.
Vous voyez, devant
un capteur standard,
comme il y a sur tous les téléphones
ou tous les appareils photo,
on est capable devant chaque pixel
de faire pousser et de construire
une petite grille de polariseurs.
C'est comme si, devant chaque pixel,
vous étiez capable de mettre
un petit polariseur
de genre.
Là, c'est pas tout à fait
la même technologie.
Sont gravés,
ils sont nanostructures et on les oriente
selon quatre directions verticales
et horizontales, diagonales comme ça,
comme ça, et avec ces quatre directions
sur chaque groupe
de quatre pixels,
on a les quatre directions.
Et en reconstituant,
en utilisant ces groupes de quatre pixels,
on peut.
On peut reconstituer
une image de polarisation instantanée
sans avoir besoin de tourner des filtres,
comme on l'a vu.
On peut même le faire en couleur
et c'est genre de caméra
qu'on a embarqué à Concarneau.
Là, vous voyez l'aquarium et Fred
qui est en train de causer à la seiche.
La petite caméra,
elle est là ? Oui, c'est très compact.
On fait des petites
caméras capables de mesurer
ça. Je vais passer.
Je n'ai pas le temps, mais c'est techno,
un peu plus avancé sur ce principe là.
Et je voulais vous parler
un peu d'astronomie.
Ça, c'est ça. C'est ancien.
C'est pas des applications modernes,
mais très vite ça c'est
que j'ai dit pas de bêtises.
J'ai un trou
en tout cas.
Mince comment ?
Il s'appelait ?
Peu importe.
Donc c'est un astronome français qui,
dès le début, on s'est créé des lunettes,
des prismes polarisants,
mais ça, dans un dans une lunette,
il commence à observer la lune et sur ce,
il observe que sur un océan lunaire
ou sur un continent lunaire, on n'a pas
la même évolution de la polarisation.
Et lorsqu'il est là, on sent que
pour regarder des objets célestes,
ça peut être intéressant.
C'est très utilisé maintenant aussi en
imagerie satellitaire.
Donc ça, c'est un
c'est l'instrument polder.
Ça c'est mon parasol
qui est sur le satellite Polder trois
qui est un satellite
d'observation de l'atmosphère
et qui est muni de capteurs
Polaris métriques.
Et grâce à ça,
on est capable de venir imager ici
des contrastes de polarisation
sur la haute atmosphère
et ça permet de mesurer des propriétés
assez fines sur les aérosols.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les aérosols,
ces toutes petites particules de taille
microscopique en dessous,
qui sont dans la haute atmosphère.
Et en faisant ces cartographies, ça donne
des renseignements sur les pollutions,
et cetera Et donc ce genre d'instruments
est pas mal utilisé en astronomie,
en observation terrestre,
autres grands domaines d'application.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la spectraux
l'asymétrie stellaire.
C'est à dire que là, on embarque
dans des instruments de ce genre là,
on est capable de venir imager
ou en tout cas mesuré sur plein de canaux
spectraux, sur toutes les longueurs d'onde
en images, sur deux directions
de polarisation croisées
les raies spectrales d'une étoile
à gauche, vous avez une image du soleil
prise avec un instrument
de la NASA et on voit ici
qu'on veut la partie en noir et blanc.
On voit que sur les éruptions
des taches solaires,
vous avez des zones blanches et noires
qui correspondent
à des contrastes de polarisations
circulaires droite et gauche.
Ça ça vient d'un effet magnétique.
Il y a des forts très très forts
champ magnétique
aux endroits de ces éruptions solaires
et le champ magnétique
a un effet sur les lignes spectrales.
L'effet Zeeman qui fait qu'on
peut les observer et donc en allant
observer le spectre des étoiles,
on a leur composition gazeuse
et en observant la polarisation,
on a une information
sur la réactivité magnétique.
Tout ça à distance.
Alors des applications encore plus folles.
Ça, c'est le collègue de l'université
de Leiden en Hollande qui
les premières observations
sur des nébuleuses.
Mais ça, c'est
la nébuleuse du Crabe observée par Oort
dès les années 56, en polarisation.
Il avait vu une petite polarisation
là dedans.
Alors maintenant,
ça ressemble à ça avec Hubble, hein.
Mais maintenant,
on est capable de les regarder.
Des contrastes de polarisation
sur des jeunes étoiles.
Et là, on voit que le disque de formation,
le disque d'accrétion
autour de l'étoile, est très polarisé.
Pourquoi ? C'est ce qui est illustré ici.
C'est que la lumière,
quand elle arrive sur des poussières
ou des poussières en accrétion autour
d'une étoile, vont être diffusées.
La diffusion a tendance à polariser
et donc ça permet de renseigner
sur les propriétés
de ces disques proto circum stellaires.
Et ça, alors,
ça a été fait par l'équipe de Leiden.
C'est la première image.
Là, c'est pas encore ça,
mais ça va être la première image
d'une polarisation d'une exoplanète.
Ça, c'est une petite exoplanète.
Alors là, je trouve un pointeur petite exoplanète voisine d'une très grosse étoile,
et ils ont été capables de
mesurer
pour la première fois en polarisation.
Et donc ça les renseigne
sur la façon dont la planète
va diffuser la lumière de
leur étoile de l'étoile voisine.
Alors ils sont encore plus fous
dans ce labo là, Ils essaient.
Je vous ai parlé de l'homo
irréalité du vivant tout à l'heure.
Un horizon pour projet d'aller
mettre des instruments dans l'espace
en orbite
pour aller regarder les exoplanètes
et essayer d'aller voir dans les lignes
spectrales,
dans les lignes spectrales
qui intéressent la végétation.
Ils vont essayer d'aller
regarder des traces,
un contraste de polarisation.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils espèrent
peut être voir sur une autre exoplanète,
sur une autre planète
que nous aller voir cette histoire d'homo.
Est ce que quelque part,
il n'y a pas eu du vivant
qui aurait aussi fait
que toutes les protéines ?
S'il y a des protéines là bas,
toutes les protéines tournent à droite
ou à gauche.
Ça peut être une signature fondamentale
de la vie quelque part,
et ils ont fait une expérience.
Voyez ici sur une feuille vivante
qui meurt de plus en plus.
Et on voit qu'au bout de 22 jours,
il n'y a plus de contrastes.
Polar symétrique,
tandis qu'au premier jour,
dès que la feuille est encore vivante,
vous voyez
sur sept sur sept
bandes spectrales de la végétation,
on a un contraste
et donc ils ont observé en labo.
On n'est pas sur des exoplanètes,
mais en labo, ça marche.
Ils ont pour ambition de faire ça
dans l'espace bientôt.
Autre.
Mais je ne vais pas m'étendre dessus.
Vous avez dans quinze jours
un collègue du C.A., David Elbaz,
Monsieur Elbaz, qui viendra vous parler
de l'histoire de l'univers
vu par la lumière, lu par la lumière.
Si on veut,
il vous parlera très certainement de ça.
Ça, c'est le fond diffus cosmologique
vu par le satellite Planck
et en fait dans fond diffus cosmologique.
Donc ce n'est pas de l'optique,
on est sur des micro-ondes
et en fait
on a des traces de polarisation,
on a des contrastes de polarisation
et ça ça excite énormément
les astrophysiciens puisque là dedans
se cache un peu des infos.
Les seuls indices qu'on pourrait avoir
sur les phases d'accroissement
de l'univers dans la zone
où ils n'étaient pas observables
puisqu'il n'y est pas encore.
Les photons étaient pas libres,
on ne pouvait pas les observer.
Donc on est à la limite de l'observation
possible.
Et c'est peut être
dans la polarisation de ce fond diffus cosmologique que se cacherait des infos sur
cette
structuration primordiale de l'univers.
Voilà.
Alors, en deux mots,
une autre énorme
application de la polarisation, ça va être
les télécommunications optiques.
Alors les fibres optiques,
les câbles à fibres optiques
transatlantiques transocéaniques,
il y en a quelques centaines.
C'est pas énorme, mais à chaque fois,
c'est quand même des installations
monstrueusement lourdes.
C'est à dire
que ce genre de câbles au milieu,
vous avez la petite fibre optique
où passe l'information, la lumière autour.
Il faut plein de trucs
pour le rendre solide.
Il faut des bateaux pour les dérouler.
Il faut des répéteurs pour répéter
l'information tous les 50 kilomètres.
C'est monstrueux.
Donc ce n'est pas comme ça
de déployer un câble.
Mais c'est grâce à ça
qu'on a Internet haut débit.
Transcontinental.
Et là dedans,
il y a des fibres et certaines fibres
peuvent être polarisées, polarisant,
c'est à dire conserver la polarisation.
Alors juste pour la petite histoire,
il y en a de ce type là.
Il y a des petits barreaux solides
qui contraignent le cœur de la fibre
où la lumière passe au milieu là, Et
en fait, on appelle ça des fibres penda,
parce que ça peut peut être de Penda.
Et celle là, on appelle ça des fibres
bonne taille, nœud papillon, parce que là,
on a des barreaux de contrainte
en forme de nœud papillon.
Et ça, ce genre de fibre peut,
si on injecte bien la lumière sur la bonne
polarisation, elle est propagée,
La polarisation se conserve
et c'est ce qu'il
faut pour attaquer ce genre de composants.
Je ne rentre pas dans les détails,
mais c'est des composants qui permettent
d'aller faire de la modulation optique
à très haut débit.
Donc les records de modulation
optique basés sur des effets
avec des objets anisotropes
dont on parle depuis le début des records.
Actuellement,
c'est de l'ordre de 100 de secondes, 100
milliards de zéros et de un par seconde
encodée sur une fibre.
Et pour finir, ce que je déborde
pour finir,
une autre application moderne de la
de la polarisation quantique.
Bref, on en a parlé il y a quinze jours,
on peut encoder sur de l'optique
et sur la polarisation.
On peut encoder les fameux Cubitt
dont il a parlé il y a quinze jours.
Et c'est quoi des Cubitt ?
C'est des chiffres
et des éléments d'information qui sont
pas des zéros, pas des un.
Vous savez que les bits de quand ?
Les bits normaux qui permettent
d'encoder l'information
sur nos ordinateurs
ce sont des zéro ou D1 ?
La révolution quantique de l'information
de l'informatique quantique,
ce serait de manipuler des bits
qui sont à la fois des zéro
et des un
qui sont dans un état intermédiaire
entouré
d'un état de superposition d'états.
On appelle ça ça en optique, c'est
à dire que c'est
facile à faire, mais on peut utiliser
la polarisation pour le faire
puisque vous voyez,
si je en fait, quand j'en vois
un photon non polarisé sur un
ce qu'on appelle un beam speaker,
un objet qui va couper
mon mon faisceau en deux temps que je n'ai
pas détecté.
Où est passé mon photon ?
S'il est passé à droite ou à gauche,
je peux considérer
qu'il est en superposition d'états
et donc grâce à ça
je vais pouvoir faire des tas de choses.
C'est assez facile
à manipuler la polarisation,
je vous ai montré qu'on sait la manipuler.
On peut manipuler des bits
assez facilement.
Donc ça je vais passer.
C'est des protocoles de communication.
De cryptographie quantique
qui sont basées sur de la manipulation.
C'est pas des huit bits normaux,
mais on a besoin de ressources quantiques
à photons uniques et on peut.
En utilisant des photons uniques
encodés en polarisation,
on peut faire des protocoles
de cryptographie,
de partage de clés secrètes sécurisées
et peut être encore plus facilement.
Donc c'est ça, c'est
la création d'états intriqués.
Donc on est on a des objets
qui sont en superposition d'états
intriqués, donc on m'en a parlé aussi
il y a quinze jours.
Donc ça se fait dans des cristaux
particuliers
qui sont aussi anisotropes,
qui sont non linéaires.
On envoie un faisceau laser un peu intense
et là dedans,
vous voyez, ça crée
deux cônes de lumière à l'intersection
des deux cônes de lumière
dans les deux points vert.
Là, vous avez
la création de ce genre d'états.
Donc si c'est
les fameuses états jumeaux, là
on crée, fait des paires de photons
intriqués qui vivent leur vie
de façon couplée.
Je ne vais pas dire indépendamment
je n'aime pas cette image.
On va vraiment voir,
on va voir intriqués
les deux photons, c'est à dire
qu'on n'a plus vraiment
deux particules indépendantes.
On a un objet quantique
qui qui englobe les deux particules,
une façon de le représenter.
Et ça, ça vaut ce que ça vaut.
Ce n'est pas de moi.
Mais si vous voyez une espèce de glu
qui va lier les deux photons entre eux.
Et donc on a créé des objets quantiques
très particuliers.
Et ça, c'est tout.
Dernier résultat
qui a été obtenu à Glasgow, notamment
par un collègue de film qui est français,
qui fait de très belles choses là bas.
Ils ont réussi, grâce à ce genre
de source, de photons intriqués,
ils ont réussi à faire de l'holographie
ça avec l'holographie.
Ça permet d'enregistrer des objets
en 3D, mais il faut pour ça
faire interférer un
faisceau de lumière de référence avec,
un faisceau qui est passé par l'objet.
Et là,
ils arrivent à enregistrer un hologramme
sans avoir besoin de faire interférer
la lumière de référence avec la lumière
qui est passée dans l'objet en se basant
sur des ressources quantiques.
Je n'ai pas du tout
le temps de rentrer dans les détails, mais
c'est des résultats très récents.
d'Optique quantique et d'imagerie
à base d'optique quantique et de photon
et de polarisation.
Voilà, donc j'arrive au bout.
J'ai déjà beaucoup.
Tout ça pour vous dire
que c'est passionnant et que ça rejoint
vraiment plein de domaines
de la physique et de la biologie.
Et donc tout ce qui relie, c'est le slide
que je mets au début de mon cours.
Mais je vous l'ai mis à la fin.
Voilà ce qui relie tous ces phénomènes.
C'est cette histoire de polarisation.
On aurait aussi le temps de parler
de l'imagerie radar
dans le radar
et d'autres domaines de longueurs d'ondes.
Mais il y a aussi
les effets paramétriques.
Il y a une équipe à Rennes
qui sont spécialistes
du traitement de signal
radar pour l'asymétrie
et je termine pour remercier
les tutelles
dont j'ai fait partie
ou dont je fais partie, notamment
pour nous avoir permis
de faire cette résidence d'artiste.
J'ai mis une toute petite vue
du making of.
On a quand même honoré notre cher Seiches
qu'on a été embêté pendant trois jours
à Concarneau.
Et voilà.
Donc ça a été passionnant de bricoler
dans les caves du labo,
de faire des trucs
plus ou moins plus ou fous.
En tout cas, on s'est bien amusé
et j'espère que l'expo vous plaira.
Avant de terminer, je
voudrais juste faire un petit coup de pub
puisque je reviens encore dans quelques
mois, juste avant la fin de l'expo.
On va faire à Au diapason à l'université
de Rennes, une soirée arts et sciences.
L'idée, ça sera cette fois ci,
non pas de faire un cours de physique
comme là, mais de faire un débat,
une discussion avec Fred, Flavien
et Thomas sur l'interaction.
Comment s'est passé
cette cette résidence d'artiste ?
Cette co-création ensemble
à la frontière des arts et de la science ?
Et ça sera suivi par un grand moment
qui sera la performance
sonore, le concert de Thomas Poli
qui va nous jouer
sa composition pour l'exposition
Au diapason, avec aussi une performance
visuelle de Fred et Flavien
et ça sera le 15 février.
Je vous invite à venir aussi.
Ça, c'est autre chose,
mais à mon avis très intéressant aussi.
Voilà, je vous remercie beaucoup
et j'espère que vous avez des questions.
Je suis
Merci Julien, Merci Julien.
Vous avez vraiment bossé pour pour faire
cette cette conférence
entre manip et et le powerpoint.
Merci beaucoup.
Alors il y a il y a 300 spectateurs
qui nous ont rejoints là au cours de la
de la soirée sur sur YouTube.
Je vais vous donner la parole.
Si vous avez des questions,
je vais vous poser une question qui,
parce que je la trouve
rigolote sur YouTube
est ce que votre chemise capable
de polariser la lumière, alors ?
Non, je rêve d'une chemise qui ferait ça.
Ceux qui me connaissent savent que j'ai
une collection de chemises
un peu particulières, non bluffantes,
avec des lunettes rouges et bleues.
Elles,
ça donne quelque chose d'assez troublant.
Voilà.
Et puis je vous donne la parole à vous,
bien sûr, maintenant, parce que vous avez
certainement des questions
à poser à notre conférencier.
Bien sûr, il a déjà préparé sa question
avant de venir.
Et puis peut être d'autres.
Vous nous faites signe
et on vous donne le micro.
Il y en a aussi pas mal sur sur Internet
et on retrouve des habitués.
Je salue Fanny et son petit garçon,
enfin son petit garçon
qui devient grand maintenant,
mais qui est un fan
de ce qui est scientifique.
Il habite Saint-Malo.
Alors de temps en temps, ils viennent ici
quand il n'y a pas école le lendemain.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas cette semaine,
elle pose des questions.
Tout à l'heure. Je vous donnerai,
je prendrai une de ces questions.
André La question d'André Quelles seraient
les applications en codage ?
Vous parliez de coder des messages
avec des effets de polarisation différents
pour essayer d'avoir décodage
ultra secret
pour envoyer les messages éventuellement.
Alors oui, ça peut être.
On peut se dire que c'est une façon
d'encoder la lumière de façon discrète.
C'est ce qu'on se dit,
c'est ce que font les seiches.
Elles encode un message discret.
On n'a pas dit secret parce qu'on a.
Si j'ai un filtre polarisant,
je vais pouvoir le révéler.
Mais effectivement, il faut savoir.
Il faut.
Il faut être au courant qu'il y a un
message qui se cache dans la polarisation.
Donc on peut.
On pourrait imaginer
avoir une communication discrète
qui se révélerait uniquement
avec le récepteur
qui a un mécanisme
d'analyse de polarisation.
Bon, malheureusement, je pense que c'est
un système d'encodage
un peu facile à déjouer.
Alors en l'occurrence,
j'ai parlé de, j'ai mentionné des
applications défense de des camouflages.
On essaye de voir des
des objets dissimulés
et on les révèle par cet
ce contraste de polarisation.
Donc c'est plutôt comme ça que c'est
utilisé en tentative de camoufler.
Et ça excite pas mal les gens des médias,
des agences de défense.
Parce que si on était, parce que c'est
très dur à faire, c'est reproduire,
reproduire
une signature spectrale,
c'est à dire la réponse d'un objet,
d'un matériau en spectral
pour mimer une végétation.
Mais on sait le faire.
On sait faire des peintures sur un tank,
on sait même faire des peintures
qui non seulement sont vertes, mais
qui ressemblent à la signature spectrale
de la végétation.
Mais ce qui est beaucoup plus dur à faire,
probablement
c'est de faire des peintures
non seulement spectrales, mais aussi
qui vont reproduire la polarisation.
Parce que le métal, tout ce qui va
aux objets manufacturés ou objets
métallisés va avoir tendance à polariser.
Donc c'est pour ça que ça utilisé
pas mal des camouflages.
Alors après d'autres applications,
j'ai parlé à la fin très vite, mais c'est
de la cryptographie quantique, alors c'est
pas tout à fait de la cryptographie,
c'est du partage de clés secrètes
par des ressources quantiques.
Et la plus part peut être pas la plupart,
mais une bonne partie des technologies
qui servent à faire ça.
Ça est basé sur de l'optique
et notamment en polarisation.
Alors est ce qu'il y a un lien entre
la polarisation, les aurores boréales ?
Bonne question.
Je ne sais pas,
c'est probable,
mais je ne suis pas certain.
Bon, j'étudie la question une autre fois.
Une Autre question
que je prends sur Internet
le fait que les carapaces de scarabées
influencent la polarisation
joue t il
un rôle dans le camouflage des scarabées ?
Je ne pense pas que ça joue
un rôle dans leur camouflage.
On, on sait pas.
Je ne sais pas bien
pourquoi ils ont cette propriété là, mais
c'est sûr,
ça reste en débat, mais c'est fascinant.
Moi, ce que je trouve le plus fascinant
dans tout ça, c'est ce que j'ai dit.
C'est cet cet homo qui est réalité.
A priori, tous les scarabées
vont tous polariser la lumière
dans un sens et pas dans l'autre.
Ça c'est assez dingue.
Pas de questions dans la salle.
Si on vient vers vous madame.
En attendant,
je pose la question du petit Oscar.
Donc du petit Oscar qui devient grand
je ne sais plus quel âge.
Là, j'ose pas trop dire
parce que ça va le vexer.
Si je le rajeuni aussi, je le vieillis.
Il demande quel est le rôle
de la polarisation dans le fait
que les arcs en ciel soient doubles,
voire plus ?
Je pense pas qu'il y a un rôle
parce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure.
C'est que la lumière qui se,
qui se réfractée,
qui se respecte deux fois
dans la goutte
pour créer l'arc en ciel primaire,
acquiert une polarisation
dans l'arc en ciel secondaire.
Elle se rétracte trois fois, elle se
rétracte deux fois et réfléchit deux fois.
Je pense que de la même façon,
très probablement,
elle est polarisée de la même façon
que ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure.
D'accord, madame vous avez le micro.
Puis il se trouve
que dans le nouveau numéro de
Pour la science et un article
sur la migration des oiseaux,
le repérage des oiseaux migrateurs
et on fait appel à deux notions
que j'ai du mal
à comprendre et à séparer c'est
le magnétisme et la polarisation.
Quand vous vous parlez de la polarisation,
vous parlez bien
de phénomènes électromagnétiques,
c'est à dire de deux champs et l'un
ces champs concerne le magnétisme.
Alors, est ce que vous pouvez m'aider
à mieux m'y retrouver là dedans ?
Oui, c'est une très bonne question
et ce n'est pas facile à comprendre
et pas facile à répondre non plus.
Alors déjà j'ai pas lu cet article,
donc je ne peux pas forcément en parler
sur la question des oiseaux.
D'abord
répondre là dessus
sur la question des oiseaux, on sait quand
on a exploré les pistes de lien
avec la biologie, on a rencontré
pas mal de référence
qui citaient que certains oiseaux
seraient capables de voir
la polarisation de la lumière dans le ciel
et s'en servir pour se guider.
Ça, à notre connaissance,
c'est pas tout à fait prouvé,
c'est même plutôt remis en cause.
Il semblerait que,
en tout cas de ce que je suis capable
d'en dire,
je ne sais pas,
je ne suis pas biologiste des oiseaux.
Il semblerait que ce n'est pas prouvé.
Alors la question que vous amener
est différente
quelle est la différence
entre le magnétisme terrestre,
les de champ magnétique
qui vont entourer notre notre terre
et la différence
entre une onde électromagnétique ?
Alors le problème, c'est que ça elle même,
c'est le même mot qui désigne
pas tout à fait la même chose.
Pourtant, c'est à la fois
on parle bien de champ magnétique.
Le distinguo est subtil.
Quand je vais avoir rayonnement d'une,
onde,
donc rayonnement, c'est à dire
propagation de quelque chose
d'un photon, alors ça peut être
un photon de lumière visible.
Ça peut être un photon de lumière.
Rayons X,
ça peut être un photon de lumière.
Radio radiofréquence.
Dès que j'ai
propagation émission de quelque chose,
ça va être forcément un couple de champ.
Et B la particule qui porte
le rayonnement, c'est le photon.
Quand on adopte une vision en physique
des particules,
y ici,
le photon, c'est ce couple champ bébé.
D'accord.
Maintenant, je vous l'ai
dit, on ne peut pas couper un photon.
On ne peut pas prendre un photon
lui arracher son champ. Heu.
Et garder que le champ B, ça
ça n'existe pas.
On détruit le photon. Il n'y a plus
de champs électromagnétiques.
En revanche, il peut y
avoir des phénomènes
qui créent du champ électrique tout seul.
Si je prends ce que j'ai pris
tout à l'heure,
mes petites électrodes, j'ai appliqué.
Mais attention, je vais créer
un champ électrique tout seul.
Mais là, il n'y a pas de propagation.
J'ai un champ statique qui se crée entre
deux électrodes et le champ magnétique.
C'est
ce qui va se créer autour de la Terre.
On peut voir ça comme un gros aimant.
Ce champ électrique
va me créer des lignes de champ
de ce champ, lui river cet aimant.
Ce dipôle magnétique va me créer
des lignes de champ magnétique.
Mais il n'y a pas à nouveau
d'effet de propagation.
Oui, c'est ça la petite.
Ce n'est pas facile à distinguer,
il faut
les deux pour qu'il y ait propagation.
Et tout ce que j'ai raconté
sur la polarisation,
c'est sur des ondes qui se propagent.
Donc tout ce que j'ai raconté,
c'est sur des champs web couplés.
Mais vous avez raison, quand polarisation,
on a très vite tendance à oublier
le champ B.
Après je vous ai parlé de champ
et comme ça le champ
est comme ça
et on ne parle plus du champ B,
c'est comment dire.
C'est une convention en physique
de définir
la polarisation,
la direction et la trajectoire du champ.
Mais en fait, il y a aussi un champ B
qu'on met sous le tapis.
J'ai mis sous le tapis
à part pour mon premier slide.
Je vous ai dit qu'il y avait un champ,
un champ B
et après je l'ai mis sous le tapis
comme tout le monde fait.
Mais j'aurais peut être dû insister
là dessus
parce qu'effectivement,
c'est pas tout à fait clair,
mais c'est
d'abord pour vous remercier.
Merci pour la réponse.
Si. Et qu'est ce que c'est
que précisément ?
Les pixels.
Alors qu'est ce qu'on appelle un pixel ?
C'est l'élément élémentaire.
C'est le point élémentaire
qui va permettre de créer une image.
Là, moi, j'ai un écran devant moi.
Chaque point de l'écran.
Quand vous allez zoomer,
vous pouvez le faire très facilement,
mais une toute petite goutte d'eau.
Vous avez peut être déjà vu ça
sur un écran de smartphone,
mais une toute petite éclat d'eau
et sur la goutte,
ça va faire un effet de loupe,
un effet de lentille optique
et vous allez tout de suite
voir des points lumineux apparaître
rouge, vert, bleu.
En fait, pour créer une image couleur,
on a des groupes de quatre puis
quatre pixels
de deux verres, un rouge, un bleu
et ces groupes de quatre pixels
qu'on allume plus ou moins
avec les effets que j'ai montré,
vont permettre de créer une couleur,
une transmission,
une intensité lumineuse et une couleur.
Donc le pixel, c'est la
le point élémentaire.
Comme sur la tapisserie.
Vous avez peut être vu l'exposition,
il y a une tapisserie au point
d'Aubusson, donc le pixel c'est
le point élémentaire d'une broderie.
Si vous voulez,
dans votre
note,
ne parlez pas comme ça parce que ça passe
pas dans l'enregistrement
et dans votre démonstration.
Quand vous montrez le petit pixel,
le petit carré, c'est symbolique,
alors c'est rare.
Ce n'est pas un vrai pixel, c'est
un énorme pixel.
Si vous voulez un pixel géant
dans un écran,
c'est la même chose,
mais de taille micrométrique.
Oui. Voilà, merci.
Est ce que ça a à voir aussi
avec cette question ?
Mes lunettes de soleil polarisées
m'empêchent
de voir l'écran de certains téléphones
et pas d'autres.
C'est lié à la technologie de l'écran.
Alors oui,
c'est lié à la technologie de l'écran.
Je crois que effectivement,
il y a certaines marques
fruitières, symboles en fruit.
Là, je crois que la polarisation
qu'ils émettent est circulaire,
justement pour éviter qu'avec des lunettes
polarisées, selon comment
on tourne son smartphone ou sa tablette,
on éteignent
le signal.
Mais moi aussi
j'ai des lunettes polarisants.
Je sais, ça arrive aux stations service,
sur les afficheurs à cristaux liquides,
les stations service.
Mais ces lunettes, on ne marche pas.
En Fait il faut enlever les lunettes
parce qu'on est justement polarisées
dans le mauvais sens.
Alors les petits écrans, c'est polarisé
à 45 degrés comme celui que j'avais là.
Oui, la polarisation est oblique
et sur les grandes télés de grande taille,
c'est des polariseurs verticaux.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Vous avez expliqué,
vous faites votre écran ?
Ah oui, j'oubliais là alors cet écran.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ?
En fait, je diffuse une image,
mais vous la voyez pas ?
Parce qu'en fait, c'est
un écran modifié que m'a modifiée Flavien
Flavien, spécialiste de ça.
Dans l'exposition,
vous allez voir plusieurs trafiqués.
C'est des écrans
télé dans lesquels on a enlevé
la couche externe, le polariseur externe
qui permet de révéler l'image.
Donc on a dans un écran,
on a une source de lumière,
un polariseur qui fixe
un axe de polarisation,
puis la dalle avec tous les petits pixels
de cristaux liquides
qui vont permettre de contrôler
la polarisation en sortie.
Et puis il faut rajouter un polariseur
pour révéler l'image révélée
la transparence,
parce que mes yeux ne sont pas sensibles
à la polarisation.
Donc ce que vous voyez filmé par le haut
quand c'était tout blanc,
c'est qu'en fait
il y a bien une image qui est diffusée,
mais nos yeux
et la caméra n'est pas capable de le voir.
Il faut que je mette mon polariseur
par dessus pour révéler l'image.
Voilà, c'est bien de le dire quand même.
Oui, c'est le feu de l'action.
J'ai oublie au passage
vous le dit Oscar, il a dix ans.
C'est
un fan de physique incroyable, de science.
Ce gamin était absolument incroyable.
Bon, et si la lumière est réfléchie ?
Me demande Boubacar Diallo.
Est ce que sa longueur d'onde varie ?
Non. Alors dans tout ce que j'ai parlé,
on reste dans le domaine de l'optique
linéaire,
c'est à dire tous les phénomènes.
La longueur d'onde ne change pas, alors ?
Pas tout à fait précis.
La longueur d'onde peut changer
quand on passe dans un milieu
plus fringant
ou la vitesse de la lumière diminue
et la longueur d'onde aussi se contracte.
Votre Kiko met la couleur ne change pas.
En fait,
quand on dit que la couleur est liée
à la longueur d'onde, c'est
la longueur d'onde dans le vide,
on fait toujours référence à la longueur
d'onde dans le vide
et cela n'a pas de raison de changer.
Que ce soit un effet de polarisation ou
un effet de réflexion ou quoi que ce soit,
comme je voyais autre chose.
Ah oui, le nom que vous cherchiez
tout à l'heure, ce n'était pas Argo,
c'est ça ?
Eh bien bravo Fanny,
vous l'auriez mettre d'Arago ?
C'est elle
qui, en plus, on l'a, on l'a utilisée dans
ce polar.
Et on y a un exemplaire de ce polar
dans les collections universitaires
de l'université de Rennes.
Un collection d'instruments anciens
qu'on a mis en valeur
dans une des pièces de l'exposition.
Il y a eu un tournage sur.
C'est sur ces instruments anciens
qui étaient destinés
à observer de la polarisation
et mise en scène au milieu d'oiseaux
justement, puisqu'il y avait
cette conjecture que les oiseaux
seraient capables de voir la polarisation.
Pas de questions dans la salle.
Vous êtes fort, vous savez tout.
S'il y a une question qui arrive derrière,
on vous passe le micro.
Voilà, merci, Bonjour,
merci pour la conférence.
J'avais une question
quand vous vous avez parlé
des exoplanètes et de leur possible
détection avec la polarisation.
Est ce qu'il a une certaine limite ?
Si on détecte très peu de lumière,
est ce qu'on peut quand même voir
la polarisation de la lumière détectée ?
Ou il y a une limite avec la distance ?
Ou alors, comme ça, je ne suis pas sûr
extrêmement vite et c'est extrêmement dur
de faire ce qu'ils ont fait.
Donc cette équipe à l'Eden est spécialisée
justement
dans ce qu'on
appelle des chronographes stellaires.
Vous savez, chronographe pour
pour voir le soleil.
C'est un dispositif qui permet de masquer
la majorité soleil, de regarder
la couronne et en fait, pour observer
des exoplanètes, C'est une des solutions.
C'est ça aussi,
c'est d'être capable de masquer
la lumière qui provient de l'étoile
centrale de l'étoile
l'étoile centrale.
Et ça, c'est très dur à faire.
Et notamment, cette équipe de Leiden
a proposé des dispositifs
à base de lames polarisants
dans des effets de polarisation.
Je ne pas rentrer dans les détails,
mais ils sont capables de créer
des chronographes pour exoplanètes
à base de polarisation.
Ils arrivent à éteindre
très très fortement, à atténuer très
fortement le signal de l'étoile centrale
et ce faisant,
ils arrivent à révéler l'étoile
satellite, la planète exoplanètes
et à avoir suffisamment
de contrastes de dynamique
pour mesurer la polarisation.
Mais ce n'est pas du tout du tout
tout facile.
C'est pour ça que ça 2021
pour la première détection en polarisation
d'une exoplanète,
plus de question.
Alors on vais encore apprendre une ici.
L'antimatière polarise t elle
dans le sens inverse de la matière ?
Alors là, je n'avancera pas Là dessus.
Il est trop tard pour répondre à
je n'en sais rien.
Trop compliqué. Bon,
eh bien, je crois que c'est tout.
Alors on va en rester là.
André, Il viendra poser cette questions,
Il en a encore une autre à poser.
Il viendra la poser directement à Julien
tout à l'heure.
Ben voilà. Merci, Merci vraiment Julien.
Parce que c'est un sujet
pas facile non plus à traiter.
Merci à vous pour
cette belle conférence.
Et puis merci à toute l'équipe, à Flavien
Terry, à Fred Murie et à Thomas Poli.
Et vraiment,
allez voir cette cette belle exposition
qui est donc dans la salle Anita-Conti.
Profitez en pour venir
voir la belle exposition.
Sur le magnétisme aussi,
puisque ça a aussi à voir
et qui est en place à l'Espace
des sciences.
Dans notre salle, Je Euréka !
Voilà.
Et puis et puis merci à toute l'équipe.
Parce que voilà, il y avait tout
un travail de préparation à faire.
Merci à l'équipe de
la régie des Champs Libres et
merci à notre équipe vidéo
qui est cachée quelque part et qui
et qui suit et qui vous permet aussi
de revoir ces conférences.
Je vous rappelle, on en a
plus de 350 maintenant dans la collection
des Mardis de l'Espace des sciences,
sur le site de l'Espace des sciences
ou sur notre chaîne YouTube.
Voilà, je crois que je vous ai tous dit
bonsoir, merci.
Rentrée bien et à la semaine prochaine.